the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the 2023 Grand chess tour is underway at
the superbed rapid and Blitz in Warsaw
Poland local fans packed the playing
Hall and Poland Stars took advantage
Hometown hero radislav voitasek played
brilliantly defeating world number one
Magnus Carlson out of the gate reigning
Champion polish number one John Pierce
South Duda looks ready to defend his
title winning his first two games for a
share of the co lead there's a three-way
tie at the top who will rise to the
occasion and take charge
day two of Epic just coming up next
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back just fans to day two here
in Warsaw Poland at the Superbad rapid
and Blitz behind me is the iconic Palace
of culture and science here in the
middle of Warsaw well we've had some
exciting trusts in day one what will Day
2 bring to us let's go to the studio and
find out
we welcome you to the second stop on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of Superbad Poland
we come to you live from the San Luis
chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining us I'm International Master Nazi
Pai kids and I'm here with Grandmaster
yesterawan Nasi I tell you and bar are
becoming super pros and the commentary
it's great it's great day one Magnus
stumbling out of the blocks what did you
think of that very surprising let's see
if he can recover indeed Lance hello
everyone and Welcome to our coverage of
the grand chess tour wow uh day one
really started with the bank 60 of the
games were decisive just stop and think
about that for a second as there's a big
pile up at the top now does he do the
honors and tell us where our standings
are after three rounds of Rapid right we
have three leaders Wesley saw levonne
Iranian and Jan Christoph Duda share in
first place impressive with plus one
score mvl and radoslavoitashek
50 richer rappert yeah and here it comes
there's one score Magnus Carlson wow
doesn't that look like a typo the one
point
and uh baghdan Daniel dieck with zero so
far and our format
we have a template around robin
tournament and in the racket uh we have
time time control of 25 minutes with 10
second increment right and the
non-traditional scoring system with two
points for a win one for draw and zero
for loss however in the blitz will have
a traditional scoring system with 1.4
win half for drone zero for loss and
with time control five plus two nice and
no draw offers throughout and our
schedule
right we have two days of rapid and two
days of Blitz and today we will have
rounds four five and six of rackets oh
all right and bar good to see you in
studio my friend I'm telling you day one
was a bang and our co-leaders uh at the
top great stuff good to see you guys it
was a very exciting start of this
tournament and we saw some very
interesting and a lot of decisive games
let's take a look at the road so far and
so we're Wesley saw who is a type of
first he won around one game against the
ACT then Drew against Magnus and one
against Richard report
then we have Duda who won the first game
against giri then he defeated the act
and made a draw with Magnus
and Levon made a draw in the first game
against mvl then won against chefchenko
and
won against giri
and Magnus had a slow start he lost the
first game surprisingly to avoid tashek
but then made two solid draws and he's
definitely looking for a win in this
tournament
and we have the Polish players doing
really well so far Duda is leading and
with Ashok on plus one and we're gonna
go to Poland to our colleagues Anastasia
and Christian
thanks Warren welcome back chess fans to
day two here at the Superbad rapid and
Bliss and what an exciting day one
filled with Thrills and Spills exciting
chess but of course everybody's eyes
were on one Magnus Carlson the former
world champion it feels so strange to
say the former world champion but
everybody's eyes were on him and he did
not disappoint he started off with the
Polish in Poland that was a bet a gamble
it did not pay off he lost that game but
in day two he has a blank slate and he's
going to try to come back and let's see
who he starts off with in day two round
four he will be facing one player that
he's definitely in shape in this
tournament and that is Maxim vashir
lagraf who started off with a couple of
draws but then in the last round of the
day defeated Bogdan Daniel dag as we can
see from their head to head Magnus is
definitely dominant in their direct
encounter and we see their mvl is
getting ready early on Magnum there's no
signs of Magnus he usually does this he
comes in the playing hole at the last
one and we're excited to see this game
but we also have some more celebrities
coming here in uh Warsaw tell us about
that Anastasia
special day because Gary Kasparov is
going to come former world champion is
here with saw him yesterday in in Warsaw
and we are expecting him to come today
and make the first ceremonial move and
then he will appear in the studio
together with you Christian I have to
admit so many people came yesterday to
The Venue the plane Hall was fully
packed with people and can you imagine I
mean like went out of the museum and
they saw so many people waiting to enter
the museum and they didn't come for for
this reason they came to watch
grantchester super bad rapid and Blitz
tournament they wanted to see their
favorite players and the organizer had
had to satisfy everyone and in the end
they managed to do so and the the crowd
go to the play and when you and also
they signed many autographs I must tell
you that even though Max didn't start so
well he still came to the uh to the fans
and he signed and he took some photos
with them it was very nice of him he was
still trying to please the public he
came here to the studio talked to us as
well and after that gave interviews and
autographs for like 15 minutes outside
the plane hole so he was definitely
despite the fact that he lost he was
still in a great mood and he's ready to
play ready to fight for the title guys
we have so much exciting chess coming
your way from Poland back to English the
atmosphere really looks great uh there
in Warsaw and uh now see do the honors
uh laid the table for round four
pairings until our audience what they
can expect let's take a look we have
dieak playing ironian and Magnus Carlson
playing mvl wow big Marquee match-up
game right there Radford against Duda
right behind you that's a that's great
for our tournament standings uh
shivchenko against giri and boy tashek
against Wesley cell another great
Marquee matchup great fights in storm
what is players fighting for they're
fighting for a handsome prize fund the
first place winner is going to get forty
thousand dollars second place thirty
thousand third twenty five thousand
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars in total prizes all the way down
to 10th Place seven thousand dollars
thirteen Grand Chester points if you win
it clear the tournament that is if you
tied for first you're shopping at 12
points at the very top uh the player
with the most grand Chester points at
the end of the tour wins an additional
100 000 bonus so we see Richie report do
you do this I do it I have to start I
want my pieces and pawns on the central
license in the nights and the night do
you have them facing forward or sideways
sideways I'm forwards uh Kasparov was
sideways and so was Bobby Fischer but
I'm forwards how about uvar you you
adjust all your pieces at the start of
play absolutely that's the first thing I
do yes sir just make sure they're in the
middle of the squares and put the
knights also on the sideways nice as we
see the players being introduced to stay
on stage for day two round four coming
up and along with Gary Kasparov we're
going to have another
um special ceremonial first move uh from
the president of Superbad Foundation
yeah nice Augusta dragic yes
skinny
and of course Magnus will be fashionably
late yes
uh Bobby was fashionably late
question was always on time I felt that
karpov was sometimes late he would uh
arrive late how about yourself I know it
was the first one to show up I like
being early in the early years I like to
get into the mindset yeah hey the man
book I look at uh nepo at uh branding
rights in that one how about you VAR
have have you have you sported the the
man bun look no no I never keep my hair
that long yes okay just ask what about
you
I had an afro uh trust me my hair can
get really bushy as we see the audience
and again it's Monday so right be really
big crowded wow it's great for the Chess
World Chess fans uh come out and
supporting the Stars
just waiting for Duda
yeah
yeah one of the things we mentioned uh
yourself especially in NLC is why is it
that Magnus gets off to a slow start so
often
it's it's surprising right it is I think
some players kind of need to get in
shape first play a few games to
like get in the right mindset yeah you
think that's what's what goes on because
I have uh witnessed him as a very very
young boy uh 12 years old when I really
he caught my eye because he was like
2612 I mean my goodness but he's always
started slowbar and I I find that well I
mean some tournaments he just go goes
roaring off of course but mostly he is a
slow starter absolutely it takes him a
little bit of time to find his form but
once he finds it especially in the rapid
and Blitz I mean he's so natural that it
will be very very hard to stop him
clay exactly
and uh playing the Polish defense in
round one in Warsaw well that's a
statement it didn't work out but it was
a it was a it was a nice truck he Almost
Got Away With It
I mean five out of a possible six points
again in the rapid they're they're
double weighted you get two points for a
win one point
we were talking yesterday if the police
are still in the Home Advantage playing
in Poland yes they do have a lot of
support they were getting applauses
yesterday after their wins exactly that
was nice I must say my home city of
Seattle that it was awkward for me to
play in Seattle it didn't feel like home
court advantage so much as disadvantaged
because I was the I was the guy that the
reporters all wanted to talk to and I
was like go talk to those guys you know
Bob and them and uh
and here is Gary Casanova the founder of
the grand chess tour and yeah
coming out to make the first move now
there's two former world champions in
the plane
Agnes
want to play
I think Magnus said your choice
not best by test
please give people
and we have Agusta dragic of making move
for I think Richard rapper
president
[Applause]
so as we get ready for the start of
round four day two we have fireworks
yesterday there is the gone 60 of the
games were decisive compared to say 28
decisive games in the classical uh VAR
Jump Right In why why is it that in the
classical versus the rapid the decisive
number of games is so different
I think we see a lot more experimental
openings like say for example in
classical chess I don't think we'd see
Magnus played D4 B5 the Polish opening
that is true and that's why we see the
numbers are usually created in Blitz I
think it's even more so uh just people
take a lot more chances and the time
control is shorter and you know even if
you have a bad position in the opening
you still have a way to recover but in
classical chess you just have to be
really solid and try to make sure you
don't get into a big trouble out of the
opening okay we have a London uh which
has recently become very very popular
but the move
c2c3 not the tricky trappy Knight C3
that we saw in day one c2c3 tell us
about
c2c3 bars solid but
enterprising or not very solid one of
the main moves in the position and I see
lots of games in my database I see
almost 2 000 games right now so question
is there a reason why Knight's not on F3
yet
like you could start with Knight F3
right right that's usually how we played
London I suppose you have to have an
answer for an early Queen B6 whereas
maybe when you play the move C3 Queen B6
potentially could be met by Queen B3
um I I at the amateur level I have to
say I have seen the Trap multiple
multiple times somebody eagerly grabs
the pawn on B2 and this really rocks
your world when somebody plays mate in
one uh but yeah maybe c2c3 is a gives
white an easier way of Defending uh
check the game of Richie report because
uh let's take a look at that opening
whoa why is there a missing F2 upon so
okay this is the Vienna with F4 an early
teenage favorite no I never played Queen
F3 I always played Knight F3 almost
exclusively
oh wow how rare is Queen F3 VAR I I must
say I I'm I'm familiar with it myself
takes on C3 takes on C3 Queen F3 they
were in the dusty part of the library uh
still I see about 72 games played in
this position okay and I will show you
how the games usually develop here sure
after Queen F3 Bishop E6 is the main
move here
just a logical move developing the
bishop and also protecting D5 then white
can continue with the move Queen G3 or
the move Bishop F4 here Bishop F4
developing and now getting ready to play
long cast so most likely you will cast
along in this position and then black
has a few different options you can play
the move C6 protecting D5 then we
continue with long Castle then try to go
bishop d392 and try to organize and
attack if black decides to Castle Dash
so it's uh definitely let me see Queen
F3 here the main move in this position
of course is Knight F3 over 500 games
played but Queen F3 is definitely rare
here but I see some games by do both and
other Grand Masters
thank you vard Queen F3 just turning my
attention back to the Magnus Carlson
game because the players are playing
quickly and it almost looks like a kind
of a slob reversed right where where
white uh Bishop it gets hunted down
um
in this case uh well Black's Bishop gets
100 down in this case it's white uh
Knight H5 Bishop G5 F6 Bishop
H4 the desirable G5
Bishop G3 Knight takes G3 is what black
wants the problem is the Knight on H5
oops quite a big problem that's a very
big problem that would cost a pawn as
the upon night on H5 is hanging with
check thus we see the move G6 first of
all sidestepping uh G4 but also still
trying to hunt down the the bishop by
playing Knight G7 Knight F5 a lot of
maneuvering to and froing h2h3 what's
the idea behind that if you go Knight G7
Bishop G3
Knight F5
I abscond away uh with the bishop and
maybe the Knight is not that well placed
in fact black structure on the king side
looks a little bit off H2 H3 takes are
we still in theory on this one VAR only
one game I see in database yeah but
played by firusha here and against yesi
pienko and that game ended in a draw and
after CD
and yes CD Bishop D6 is played here I
like this move H3 Yasser that you
mentioned and also it gives another
option against the move Knight G7 for
example you can actually I think
consider the move G4 as well just to
restrict the Knight okay the Knight is
going to be very passive on G7 cannot
play Knight F5 uh on Knight H5 and
against the move H5 you can even play
the move for G1 for example I think this
this looks good for white and plus G6
will be very very weak as well here so
CD played and I think we're we're
following that game CD CD and the reason
you take CD here because if you take
with the E Pawn then the Knight can come
to F4 as soon as you move the bishop so
that's why we see the move CD so we have
a slav defense exchange violation
structure here but one thing we see the
Knight on the two for white is a little
bit misplaced because usually you want
that Knight on C3 in this positions
right and also the bishop on H4 always
have to be mindful of a G6 G5 especially
um once you've castled Bishop D3 okay
and well it's a developing move
um a little bit unsure if I yeah this
was my question after castles
do I want to Aspire to play the move G4
what what's your take and now see do you
like this position looks so strange to
me because for it looks like regular
slav but then it's not it's not the
pieces are misplaced the pawn structure
is different so right if white were to
play G4 then would you Castle long or
would you still Castle short it depends
uh my follow-up uh would be G4 Knight
back to G7 G5
so I'm trying to take the sting out of
E5
okay so let's say if I play F5 right and
then Bishop back to G3 now it looks a
little bit strange I'm fighting for dark
squares but I'm kind of encouraging at
the same time F4 right yes F4 is
tempting F4 and then to your question is
am I castling long likely the answer is
yes uh
um
it feels like an overreach by white I'm
not sure I actually like this position
for white and Magnus ducked the entire
conversation he did just play castle
oops let me just put that on the board
Castle short it looks a little strange
the bishop on H4 VAR give us an engine
assessment of the current position
no no you're in trouble engine engine
likes Black's position here thinks black
is actually slightly better and really
that Bishop on H4 is misplaced it's the
color and uh yeah you in this position
is a little bit different if you play
them with G4 because you already castled
yeah so slightly better for a block I
will show you a few moves how the game
can develop here so Bishop D7 I think
makes makes a lot of sense right and
just try to develop the bishop and now
bring the Rook into the game you really
it's unclear what are you really going
to do with this bishop here so you can
play let's say let's say work C1 Rook C1
and then uh there are a few different
ways you can continue with this bishop
E8 is interesting because now you're
protecting your knight and also getting
ready to play the move G5 here
now putting pressure on the bishop and
let's say Bishop E2 is already necessary
because you want to meet the move G5
Bishop G3 is always very bad but here
now you have the smooth Knight E1 right
and now you're attacking the Knight on
H5 so Knight will go to G7
your structure still gets messed Bishop
G3 yes yeah now captures
Pawn takes and now Knight can go to F5
here
I'm starting to like black and black is
really doing well here you are defending
both pawns with the move Rook F3 but
still the position looks looks bad the
weakness is on G3 and E3 as well here
yeah it does look uh well uh opening
experiment doesn't seem to have panned
out uh for our world number one keep
that in mind let's just uh jump to uh
the game of Wesley so uh remarkably
enough
um way back in the day uh this
particular line had a bad reputation
um
in the 80s but thanks to the computers
uh
wow we've seen so many games and by the
way by Wesley so himself where he makes
I don't want to say a comfortable draw
but it's like he knows what it takes to
make a draw from these positions first
first blush you go okay better structure
we King for black You've Got The Rook
already on the Deep file you're ready to
pounce on D7
but the Bishops of opposite color
actually gives black very very good
chances of holding still it's kind of
the two result game yes for sure but
Wesley has gained time he has 26 minutes
on the clock which goes to show what
amazing preparation he has
he is the returning Champion right yes
by the way uh Queen F3 let's just go to
the game of Richie and do the for a
second after the move queen of three
Bishop E6 can't argue with that move too
much I mean in this position where is
your position going to go why not to E6
defend F7 uh defend uh D5 develop a
piece life is good Bishop F4 prepping
castles and
c3c4 Queen D7 looks fine castles
C5 whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Question
Time Out Bishop C4 just went in the pawn
now uh there's a bishop G4 trick right
I'm assuming uh I'm assuming after
castles we can't play Bishop G4 right
away because
of Queen takes
sure do you want yeah
E6 on Bishop G4 white has E6 maybe what
just how do I feed it choose anything
yeah cutting the electricity okay well I
mean there goes a pawn right rip snarl
Terror
you can just take on D5 yeah serum
Bishop G4 and if Bishop D1 take on takes
on B7 exactly that was and I was looking
at uh
um Bishop with I presume Retreat I can
never play Queen C6 yeah
five Knight F3 and I win back The Rook
absolutely white is winning here okay
which which is very good news if you're
white uh after castles C5 because I want
to play Bishop C4 but Bishop G4
because if you take Bishop E6 I can take
on D5 that's what I'm thinking that now
I really I'm warming to E6 uh I always
thought of these kinds of moves as
cutting the electricity between the the
connection cutting the connection uh you
would love to take with the pawn but
that hangs the bishop uh in you take
with a queen
there's got to be some tactics here okay
and just uh
is there a made on C8 trying to find it
right right that would be funny
if there was a mate on C8 probably
I was so close so close so close uh
potentially still winning though what do
you think this is like ridiculous what
have I sacrificed the beautiful thing
about being a commentator that you're
going to really really love is when the
variation doesn't work you take all your
moves back and say sorry okay uh uh I
don't know but my first impression yeah
rating points exactly we don't get fined
or anything I don't know but I think C5
is a little bit too ambitious for her
yeah I think C5 is actually a blunder
and a blunder yeah the move you want
guys analyzing Bishop C4 is very strong
is it good very strong and also another
alternative is just to start out with
the move Knight H3 which makes a lot of
sense because you have some Knight G5
ideas coming up as well and then after
Bishop C40 Rooks are connected so it's
actually very loose move I'm surprised
he played the move C5 because he's way
behind in development and he needed to
move like C6 or even engines actually
like to move Queen A4 there yeah so get
the queen active and then get the Knight
on D7 and quickly cancel along well I
just like getting out of the exactly of
either Bishop C4 or even c3c for Queen
A4 comes with a Tempo I I must say I was
kind of expecting I didn't think
anything except Knight C6 myself Queen
A4 perfectly sensible development with
Knight C6 now tell us a little bit more
about C5 Bishop C4 uh dig a Little
Deeper on this one for us yeah Bishop C4
is Bishop C4 is very strong move now you
just want to take on D5 and the move
Bishop G4 actually it's been met by E6
which you guys were analyzing E6 is very
strong in this position if you take back
with the bishop after Bishop D5 is just
a very very big Advantage for white
simply winning here the king is stuck in
the middle so instead the best option is
to take back with the queen here
whoa and here there are a few options
you have you can take Queen takes D5
which will give you a pretty nice
Advantage here this is what we were
looking at Bishop takes Bishop D1 let's
go a little bit deeper Queen takes p7
Queen takes C4
Holy Spirit this is our line oh and
queen C8 yes that was let's see yeah I
think we went 93. actually it's it's not
super clear it looks like Bishop E2 okay
uh Rook E1 and like I said we take we
could take our moves back it turns out
our moves were actually good yeah no
they're very good in here like it's it's
lots of very strong initiative here but
black has to play Queen a queen A6 and
uh still better for white but not not a
huge Advantage here
wow as we would look at the head to head
uh wow a few games but Duda has a big
Advantage with three wins we call it 50
50. three wins three draws for Duda very
impressive and then reminding everybody
Duda is the defending champion of the
Warsaw uh grantchester from last year uh
always nice to win in front of the home
crowd I suspect that Richard is looking
and calculating the very position that
you have on your board because after
Bishop C4
if he plays Bishop C4 you can't just
allow Bishop takes D5 and resigns right
the only fighting move has to be Bishop
G4 and uh getting that variation that we
were just looking at the line we were
looking at E6 at the end I was counting
material if we're down a rook in the
minor piece
but our conversation is good enough that
why it's better that's what I'm saying
it's so hard for Richie to calculate
that so right here right now we're
threatening mate please trade my Queens
no I take a rook there goes a rook
there goes a bishop
and again this is the main line that uh
VAR and so we're down a rook and a
bishop we picked up some pawns but yeah
that's one Bishop E2 rookie
suggests white is only a better by a
smidge
continue this crazy variation for us
after Queen A6 bar yeah let's take a
look Queen takes D5 and
by the way in this position instead of
taking on D5 on move 11 there is another
alternative there is a move Queen D3
just the idea here would be if he takes
back on C4 you have a queen d8 mate
clear and if it takes on D1 that will
give you the option to capture on the
file with the bishop and this is very
strong because now V7 is hanging and if
Queen goes on D7 for example you have
Queen is for check and then you pick up
on B7 this is a nice Advantage for white
as well here but we can go that's much
cleaner yeah we can go a little bit
deeper in that line just uh just to see
Queen D5 Bishop D1 evaluation actually a
little bit drops here even for engine
the one I use it's just it's not clear
if white is actually winning here Knight
H3 Bishop E2 Rook E1
Queen A6 and here's the best move here
is to play Queen takes C5 check
and now King has to go to E8
and it looks like you're very close to
win the game but somehow it's still
black is definitely Queen D5 now
attacking The Rook
on A8 and uh
Knight C6 loses to the move Knight G5
because you have a difficulty defending
F7 but Queen C6
and actually pick up a bishop the bishop
Bishop you're still down a rook after
all this still down a rook so it's not
uh completely clear still Initiative for
why do you have a move Queen G5 here but
uh it's it's complicated to sacrifice
all this in a in a rapid game so I think
he's well you might see it yeah Bishop
Bishop C4 Richie is not backing off by
the way a game that is really racing I
want to say to
um a draw as a game uh between uh
radislav and uh Wesley Wesley looks like
he's just trying to remember his prep
are there in the Bishops of opposite
color and uh well things of things went
fast I want to put it that way when we
left it we just left it here Rook D7 F5
by Wesley give me that pawn and Wesley
got his Bishops of opposite color
position
looks like white slightly better and
then this surprise move Rook
B8 so just giving up E6 just giving up
E6 uh rookie six let's assume King G5
let's say B5
there's a small problem
right I'm assuming you
you know the crazy part is this would be
this amazing slash
you know like if Wesley has this
position at home and he's just figured
out that this bishop ending is a draw uh
remarkable stuff uh VAR jump in is this
Wesley's prep
I think so I think he analyzed this by
looking at the clock he still has almost
23 minutes wow the reason he played the
move Rook p8 is he wants to play more
actively because if he didn't do
anything that would have allowed
waitasha just to play King C2 King B3
Advance the a pawn A4 A5 in and you you
really cannot really Advance the pawns
Pawn only six is tied up but with the
Rook p8 I think it's a good move now
he's threatening to play Rook B6 right
so essentially forcing the move Rook
takes E6 and after that Lion King G5 B4
Pawn is hanging so you need to protect
it and you cannot play the move A3 Dash
because if you play a trip would be
desired move to play and then bring the
king to c2b2 but here you lose the
bishop after Rook C8 whoops so that's
why you need the move B5 and then he
will just go Rook C8 and then that that
end game he will it's just yeah he will
help this very easily the bishop coming
to B6 and then the important plan there
would be just I think to play H for H5
H4 and then King can go back and even if
you lose that five pound putting the
bishop on G3 you will make a very easy
draw there
wow put the bishop on G3 anchor the
bishop on G3 and Wesley makes an
amazingly easy draw we just start all
the way till the end game wow I'm what
can I say Richie by the way
right wow that is a remarkable
effects is in preparation I mean to
calculate this in a correspondence game
will be tough to do it and a classical
game is impressive I don't think it's
preparation because he did spend a lot
of time he's down to 13 minutes
I certainly am queen A4 Knight C6 but C5
inviting Bishop C4 and the players are
going down this uh road that we've been
analyzing or there are other games
going on uh what else of course game
yeah let's you want to go to Magnus yeah
let's check Magnus first okay so this is
a game where the engines kind of felt
that the bishop on H4 was giving
MBL a small Edge Rook E1 do your worst
this is where we thought Bishop H5 was
the intriguing idea for
black
he didn't play Queen B6 A3
sorry I'm just pausing pausing you know
why I'm pausing okay can we do too and
we'll go very quickly catch up to the
players
and the bar jump in and tell us where we
stand
but first let's throw it to Warsaw with
Christian and a very special guest
thanks yaser we are with the 13th world
champion and The Mastermind behind the
grand Chester one Gary Casper welcome
back to the show we haven't seen you
since uh Bucharest tell us about your
first impressions 10 years ago
yeah
Poland is amazing so far it seems like
the organization is just incredible this
is only the second year and it gets
better and better tell us a bit about
your first impressions sky is the limit
yes it is yes that super bad proves it
you know from one to only to another and
now just uh the super bad sponsorship
turned Eastern Europe in the definitely
in the center of just in Europe and God
knows you know against Christ is the
limits and we've seen the impact the the
playing hole is absolutely packed
yesterday you couldn't throw a needle
yeah look it's it's you have all the
best players okay ding is missing but
still it's just yeah almost all the best
players in the world and of course
Magnus who hasn't played for quite a
while so he's he's here it's a big
attraction and
and Rapid chess and bleeds always you
know it makes it a better show because
squeak it's it's Dynamic and you know
definitely that within one hour you have
some the size of games yeah
I'm not sure there's a was there any
round in in in in in uh in Rapid that
was five draws
uh maybe last year
would you have to move we have to uh
mobilize our memories
okay that's there's always blood
absolutely and speaking of the world
champion we did not know what to expect
from him coming as the first official
games as a non-former world champion
what did you uh expect from
not very impressive let's let's I watch
them online polish yeah it's
I
you know I think again this is purely my
observation I might be dead wrong so and
they definitely amped I I hope it
doesn't make him upset so I somehow I
feel it's about the same as you know as
the it's the uh with ding but the
opposite when you say world champion
thing looks around you know are you
talking to me that's it was Magnus I
think it's opposite you know so this
this he has to adjust that he's I think
arguably the best player actually this
is the best player now but he's no
longer world champion
it's let's let's think somehow it puts
pressure on you because he's
performance on day one was I mean
it was not Magnus definitely yeah yeah
exactly and this is the the way he
played it was D5 the the the the the the
game he lost the voltage because
that's the yeah he he had some games of
well that's when he played some old
moves the old brings but
um uh you know he always you know next
round he always came back and yesterday
we didn't see any comebacks it was the
it's two uneventful draws actually this
result yeah he put a little pressure on
saw but not
he did mention variance as one of his
reasons for playing the Polish and
playing a bit more losing rapid and
blisters obviously the variance is a bit
higher
um do you think this sort of gamble will
play pay off
so far it doesn't yes and it's even even
we again we don't know again actually I
cannot get into his mind because he's
definitely
um
it's going through this process of just
you know recalibrating his own
four months his own place in the world
of gesso what happened comes like I
don't know I mean look at these
positions okay
yeah what do we have here so I had some
sort of Ace love no actually uh no it
was it was London yeah yeah it's a very
popular line now it's the um that I
think um
soap Subway against mvl yes was was this
you know they're going to have this
bishop Knight H5 and F6 and then CD4
yeah and I think this mvl took with
night on D4 yes not exactly the same and
and Magnus took with C pollen
so
uh
I'm not sure if he's aware of the line
he definitely by his time Spencer at
least he doesn't feel like he's aware of
what yeah at least he was going in the
opening
but right now he's getting slowly slowly
back into it
but
C8 now yeah Rook C1 probably Rook C1
yeah this is this idea come up with A4
Knight A2 Queen before so that's the
this yes and then just
maybe just to use this so let's make
some you cannot do that because you lose
the D5
94.
you can take you know you can tell you
can take no that's that's not no no no
so that then then Rook C7 is plausible
yes yes yes yes that's maybe roxy7 yeah
yeah and then Rook C8 and
proxy 70 C8 but still probably that's
going to invite this Knight E4 I'm not
sure if you have any better alternative
she won
but yeah
[Music]
if you can connect your Rooks maybe you
can uh
you can get to my pieces but between
before yeah yeah
interesting
positions
so I'll defend there
four okay maybe Queen B4 tried for some
good
if necessary
so this is yeah that 26 is annoying yes
but it could also become a liability
yeah oh that's exactly the position
that's the position
or not yeah yeah so I was there
it actually has a lot of Alternatives
though right yes but if you don't play
Rook C7 then just you know you you you
have to wait A4 or night eight Knight A2
Queen before
that's again not the end of the world
he's going for it
I will just come on this is I I'm very
surprised he doesn't how do you uh
describe mvl as a player is he a player
that usually takes his chances
trusts his instincts
I think it's just it's almost instincts
is it's
a
about making
it's about a good call because
the position that we looked at with Rook
uh with queen and versus two Rooks it's
highly unusual it's the most complicated
type of positions where you have broken
material again it's still not broken but
queen versus two Rooks he played it
exactly thinking that's that's basically
Emerald says okay you make it you decide
I don't think you can evaluate the
position easily because because Knight
on D6 is unpleasant and Rooks are not
coordinated but it's again material
technically black has extra material
because it's
10 10 pounds versus nine points in
theory and
um uh White Knight on F1 is is really
far away from from real life so we're
with that Knight
look forward to to get to okay but you
should go down there but still even if
you want enough
and and then what yeah that's the
question yeah because eventually you can
you see it's important Bishop E6 and
then
yeah yeah
Bishop E6 and rook d8 and then I can go
by the way I can go Rook C7 and Rook one
season unite can be strapped
that's now
yeah night is nice yeah you you probably
have to start sacrificing some points
yeah G4
and try to get the nice house position
that's not no actually now let's now
realize this this Knight is in trouble
now so this is not enough
by the way we do have a result an early
one uh voitashek versus Wesley did
finish in a draw nothing unexpected
there I'm not surprising so that's the
so this is one of the popular lines now
yes there's this yeah yeah but let's go
but let's go to the report game we
should we should that's that's one
wow and you were talking about this line
with Queen F3
um have you been studying this
I always remember this is some old book
when I was a kid the queen of freeze is
is dubious move because Knight C6
Knight takes e494 so that's that's what
I remember yeah but it seems to me that
it's the uh then now they have a nice
example Bishop B5 yes and that's the
that's and that's another theory so
um no no no I just but okay so
entertaining and by the way he played in
the series in serious uh tournament in
in the classical jazz
exactly because the another salute
another
uh suggestion for black is F5 which is
just yeah that's that's also considered
a refutation but after these three it's
very very short position take take the
D4 and then I think Queen G3 or I think
Queen is
very short very very sharp yeah very
short position that's what the report
likes yeah so exactly and it works
but but I think I don't know whether
it's prepared or not but you just
do this quite quickly so this was
definitely within his preparation
I think this was the first moment when
he started thinking Queen to D7 Castle
it's too far and now Bishop C4 wow yeah
great
great world E6 it reminds me of my year
was carpool it was this coach E6 is when
you just you sacrifice the pawn and you
um destroy the coordination of the
pieces you took with the queen you you
probably has to yeah
Queen takes B7 now
okay we just do it's just absolutely
crazy stuff so what you go
Queen F1 now but who's getting
checkmated first right Queen F1
why definitely have Perpetual that's for
sure most likely is it made Quinn if one
I I bet you that after night the free
should be made tonight of three yes it
should be a mate
first the first queen see a check King
seven I bet you two that will be made
Knight F3 I probably have to take this
guy going to ac5 yeah I would be very
surprised if it's update
yeah and this is probably what he has to
start calculating he's a sequence six
and then Bishop D6
okay it's close it's very close very
close I'm not sure it's made or not but
it's close and definitely what is
Perpetual so that's that's that's
playing with no risk yeah yeah how are
we doing on time right now eight minutes
for report 11 for do that
okay Okay
no Okay Queen seed neither free that's I
would although I would have done just
instantly so
this is
what about Queen C7 now okay let's go
back to E8 I would assume yeah that's
okay now let's see because if you go
here I don't want to see right there
but also night night H3 yeah not the
phrase made the 2525 yes yes but that's
the same Bishop yes the bishop yes so um
queen of one
F1
now check we have to give a check check
we have this is this we have to get the
Queen off this diagonal yeah but square
c6l is another option but
but now we don't have Knight F3 anymore
yeah but this is you have to see a word
okay Bishop D6 yes
still not clear yeah
that's why I don't like to take this
Rook so this and I I want I want to just
do an attack at steam so but Richie is
getting down to these last six minutes
we see seven so where are you back on
the end you have to go back
I really have to go back maybe it's just
a perpetual
not that clear
ly you're crazy
the fact that your king survives
he
Queen C8 King E7
okay let's
get this night I thought maybe not from
eight but H3 doesn't f well you know you
don't have a if no king king doesn't go
only six only if my king goes three six
but it doesn't it does it does yeah I
just stay e87 yes yes okay so maybe
yanchi stuff somehow manages to survive
this one with the black pieces that
would but what does look in any case
by the way the engine right now before
Queen F1 it's saying that white is
winning
after Queen F1 the engine changes it's
mine zeros
draw yeah
he found it yeah yeah this one and right
now the pressure is on Richie I mean
he's dropping down to his last five
minutes yeah okay yes
that makes sense no there's no okay see
what uh okay this one is still so so
let's have let's just look at other
games add other games yes Magnus played
okay riddle versus Anish Anish is now
having good events so far no he's really
been struggling lost two games yesterday
not doing amazing out of the opening
with this one why
um Maybe not maybe you get checkmated
or at least
poke you around I'm terrified let's
continue
we can take on C4 before I'm just even
so terrified I can take Lucifer
ah
yeah okay
even though I'm not sure we if I want to
take with a queen or with a pawn let's
say I take it with a pawn
just because I want to have a good one
[Music]
very concrete pool is this okay what was
it he plays Rock H3 he played as well
yeah
sacrifice and think later
now big uh big find by kiril and this
will be his first victory in this one um
okay last difficult game yesterday so
what's the yeah plus one is
[Music]
10 minutes for giri 8 Min close weight
minutes for curio let's go so what's
what's what we're missing so uh uh lefon
versus well Bogdan versus Levon Bogdan
struggling in this one struggling means
what zero out of three ah yeah but this
is not not in this position in this
position he's doing well is is safe it's
absolutely safe he plays
if he plays quickly he should he can
lose this position why of course you can
but but anything is possible but it's a
very comfortable position yeah actually
I think it's just I don't know
it's very unpleasant because this is
that's kind of a dream position for
white so the stabilize the center so
this is and this is double pulls here
and um
located and then they start pushing
G3 just slowly slowly so this is now
maybe now you should Rook F2 just to
know these two yeah just to make sure
that of the H4 Knight is
yes so it's a safe Advantage for Bogdan
in this one
maybe maybe you can start even G4 now
and you did mention the time he's down
to his last three minutes against 15.
yeah that's his problem that's his big
problem maybe G4 G4 maybe makes sense
before I think we have he played G4 he
did he played you for he did yeah and
now levels should probably play H5 now
yeah I think he played Bishop Rook D7
Rook D7 ah he wants to go Knight f795
yeah but this Knight will be taken there
H4 okay no no no no no no no no no no
Rook F2 like you prescribed yeah about
this so you gotta play okay
again it's so easy for white to play can
you just read H4
um light can go on D4 but then you
always can yes he goes there
uh now you have to go go probably King
G3 Knight D4 Knight to three yeah
because you want to you want to meet
this Knight you did you just to exchange
one night and then you H4 G5 and you
create a weakness there yeah
there's something there just let them
listen yeah no uh bog down one of the
world one of the youngest competitors in
this event alongside kiril uh speaking
of young competitors
um we had the Simon
before the event started with all the
players and one of the players uh that
one is one of your people at the Casper
of Chess Foundation I think his name is
yes yeah but yes
it's not fair when the Simon come on
he's I know last year he was nearly 2200
I think now this is probably strong more
yeah
I did the series in Brazil but you've
worked with him
he's very talented yeah extremely
extremely gifted extremely gifted yeah
yeah that's that's
[Music]
let's see
oh okay
okay seems like close to a draw yeah
but
Magnus is trying the Magnus is the one
trying wood maybe go away 586 and then
try to sacrifice something and get the
night away King King goes there King
goes if I go A5 you go Bishop D7 maybe
I mean not yet yeah but the king king
goes on D6 black king goes on D6 and
yeah wait why there's no
no breakthrough points yeah yeah this
one seems to be going towards the draw
frustrating for Magnus for sure and it's
probably still just the droids this is
this that's his he's he's not doing much
you know so there's okay he's Knight
will be one yeah
King goes on D6 and then
yeah doesn't seem like much all right
looks good for MVR I think he is
not safe actually the save is a big word
save what
you hate Knight C3 they're following
yeah
the footsteps so far it's even we can
predict their moves
yeah
um
Gary uh
yeah that's the 19th century game yes
this one we're gonna stay until the end
with this one I think they're repeating
foreign
maybe we can see if they're repeating
Richie reporter versus Yan shished after
the
by the way Richie is still down to his
last three minutes
thinking trying to find something
but there's not much
that's right so this is where we came
from
we take the root King D7 you might even
be worse right no then you're out of
trouble
yeah I think you're in trouble because
maybe you'll find a Perpetual but it's
not clear
yeah I probably couldn't access seven
probably it's a Perpetual but would you
you're not gonna gamble with this no no
no it's definitely
Bishop D6 is on the board
let's see if we're going to stick into
d8 immediately
indeed
so I'm curious you know this is the
they're not the lucky level yeah yeah
exactly let's let's try let's see what
king D7 is King D7 yeah Queen B7 or
taking the king yeah King D6 yes
let's say try to run somewhere
28 Queen takes D1 that's that's because
I just yeah I want to do like a bishop
so that's that's right yes yeah that's
right
it's over exactly yeah so
so that's that's why I think it's the
yeah yeah that's very nice yeah King V8
he played
see if we can see uh
Shake of hands soon still thinking it's
phenomenal yeah
Classics yeah but I think this report
you should play you know do something
you know just to you didn't do that he
had to sacrifice
more beautiful just sacrificing all the
material yeah
yes and then just you know and then you
can spend you know all the time and give
winter seconds left
yeah that would have been nice yeah that
would be nice yes otherwise now he I
think he lost his even though he can
still do it right Queen C7 and now
Knight F3
maybe you can still do it
why not I mean go for it Richie
you're not missing anything
yeah okay yes check check yeah
we're not getting out looking
yeah
let's see what he goes for
yeah so we'll just you know check but
it's the it's not
yeah so let's see it's the if you do
this this and this this check
the queen takes C5 here but still can
get this in the second condition I think
that's that's it
okay
that's the trick oh my goodness I fell
for it I fell for it yeah
maybe he's gonna try for it maybe I
don't go for it yeah
he definitely wants to
um yeah if it's a draw you can do it
without the Rook on H1 try it out how
many uh how much time does okay 45
seconds
yesterday he did something yesterday
there's no risk yes there's no risk
that's true he tried too much uh
yesterday with the richest princess
okay that's that's that's and I like him
he's he's all strike too Until the End
yes exactly yes
he's looking for it he's looking for it
all right let's see but he goes back on
the eighth so that's unfortunately
nothing you can do about it let's see
okay but it should be so beautiful
that's such a nice game
okay
he's gonna go for it
it's level seven with xc5
and hope and hope
it seems like it might only move yes
give him a chance to make a mistake
we need four
what
you still cannot go King the seven right
why no King this have an id5 if you take
on C7 Queen C6 wow maybe it's been this
is made maybe yeah
yeah
go on F6
but you had to take one with cc5 why did
he just it was nice to take
how do you escape though oh wow okay we
have six made in two 97 95 yes he has to
go King this out
95 you cannot take Quincy 6 mate so you
have to go King E6 King e67
maybe King is seven King E6 Queen C6 and
now we're getting this G4 yeah exactly
yes and that's over so he has to go King
seven
is that might be the only way to try to
escape
and then you're just wow you always have
Perpetual you had to take the spoon with
C5 somehow I believe that's the spawn
it's always nice because you could
eliminate bonus C5
okay let's see
only one move
um well if you have taken Polo C5
eliminate Point policy five the same the
same situation with but but with
see
so take on C5 yes
now now check same situations
now okay but I have extra Square here
but maybe
this is the key moment right now okay by
the way this is but that's that's that's
that's that's that's it
that's it that's it take the phone
Queen C4
Queen F7 mate
mate oh my goodness
so I cannot go to E7 I have to go to F6
yeah okay this is mate should be made so
I'm not sure I'm not sure is it made or
uh yes I think
it is E5
H4
wait is it me
no no but first in a queen F4 me yeah
that's that's me that's the most
oh my goodness
so taking on C5 maybe was the exactly
this is just a little bit important then
and then Queen before check and it's
probably winning wow this is where we
are probably it's Evergreen game you
know 21st century
yeah without the engine we could spend a
month analyzing this position probably
but I thinking F5 staying on the light
squares taking advantage that you don't
have G4 yet maybe this is the way to
survive
wow and saying that the King on G5 is
somewhat safe
which is kind of ridiculous but you
don't have checks anymore yes yeah the
problem
so yeah no no you cannot you should
probably check Ah that's a check check
exactly check that's a problem
so now you have to okay
let's go back again
no no this is here yeah jug Queen D3
so if I go back that's something
King F6 oh no no it's not made here you
have to save story
but now you have Queen C6 right and you
there's no more king of fight because of
G4 oh yeah wow
okay this is an absolute this is amazing
yes this is an amazing game yeah I mean
absolutely amazing game wow and by the
way his really spending some time right
now do that he has to he has to I mean
because since he has only move yes King
V6 King six is the only move
yeah so that's only moves King seven
ourselves we are getting confused yes
King the seven after analyzing yeah
that's that's why I wanted C5 won't be
limited to play Queen before check yeah
continue this
whole procedure so
hunt of the king
yeah white white mobilizing there's like
all the resources very little left with
Everest every every
um
[Music]
um uh Soldier or every officer or every
General there it's all are engaged yeah
every ounce of energy going towards the
king king seven all right yes yes yes
yes
I think this is and you can see the
reaction from from reaching he knew this
was a good move yeah
you could
interesting here so okay speaking the
richness to really make a decision right
now
but now it's it's it's 40 seconds
9g4 is a perpetual and instant Perpetual
if you want to remove this In Perpetual
now Knight G6 probably the same
I go back to D7 I never go to F6 yes
black yes yes whatever big big moments
let's see what he's going to do
repeated that would have been Immortal
by to have three King to D7
Knight to E5
we've seen this from Richie though he
repeats once and then he tries to change
this okay is this around Auto steam now
that's okay he's he's two looks down
yeah okay that's what's happening bro
um let's see Magnus right now yeah
yeah a couple of things have changed
who the people
and by the way this this one is over
they did repeat the position what a
beautiful game
I don't like this is this is the C5
square is the
it's something that's you don't want to
give up voluntarily Magnus is doing what
he usually does right yeah
what are those still is yeah yeah and by
the way okay King before the King goes
to C5 as you imagine oh yeah
hearing A5 yeah but you have to be
careful about Knight C4
so that's not good by the way how are we
doing on time okay nine minutes for
Magnus Big Time Advantage three minutes
and a lot of pressure piling on and
the just amazing he just
the
question B7 but now King C5
what is this King C5 Bishop E6
and then give a chat back 96 97 and A6
is
97.
now you have to you cannot defend the
pawn because I invade
six sorry about 197 97 King before
no yeah
try to exchange the pool yeah
but it's not not any email take here
okay
this is not disturbs
silly but it is trapped
you can probably take only five
how to do it and he has the time to do
it as well he has time to find the best
news
um no this is not going to be easy for
MBO
what the other games ended yes uh yeah
uh only two games ended the arc is still
trying but yeah it's that's really true
I think this is this is only one
weakness yeah it's just I think it's the
he definitely not neither fight he he he
went there too early so only five it was
a night let's see that's why he says
it's now but again this is right here
yes 95 allow this Exchange
no but you you that's why I didn't like
neither free because it's the um
he exchanged too early the nights so you
just have to go can you see H4 G5 you
have to try to create his weakness
neither five is not a big deal so this
is after
94.3 he played yes
yes
okay
matter five exchange one of the knights
yeah exactly but that's the that's the
that's it that's all that's the wrong
idea exactly that's the wrong idea
nobody's instead of instead of moving
another H5 age 45 yeah I think it was
high levels with Highland person King G3
exactly no no but just you know you
create witness and that's the
this one is slipping away from from
bogdown yeah and kiril was doing really
well against Anish but Anish is back in
the game maybe even better how how did
he defend his position rukesh 3 was the
last movie have you seen it G6 yeah
not an easy move to to play but yeah was
this was this GTX history yes yeah that
was the key yeah that's the yes exactly
is
not easy not easy did not spot it and
after Knight E3
another story
yeah and now we have this maybe he can
save it he's still not much worse right
this one is over by the way Bogdan
versus Levon yeah we expected that okay
let's go back to Magnus right yeah six
guys we discussed they're following uh
our
our path
okay how do we continue right now
of course
after King D6 I think maybe you should
take it take take no
no B5 or A7 but it can be five I have
this is over
you're not starting
it's over okay he took on B5 of course
five now
if as we discussed 95 28
88 and now that's a six check yeah King
C8 probably King series or maybe you
start with um
actually can you see this first
otherwise it's quite nice if you lose a
PC yeah
King C8
all right how do you continue
how do you get to that D5 Pawn is the
question
um but you don't have to rush so that's
this this is the if I start with King A5
what's your next move I cannot go the
next seven next to meet you there you
cannot move the bishop because 97 check
and take 0.5
what can you move
I guess I have to go H5 or so okay H4
what's your next move that's another one
what's your next move that's another
weakness yeah no I don't like this
I don't like this yeah
I'm not having fun there's no moves King
d8 okay they're going for that ic6
and
asking to make a move King K5 show me a
next move
he's going for it now there's a problem
it's almost it's actually a dog's one
there's no move okay just the Fate just
for the sake of it is this end game
this is losing in this Pawn end game
just in case we ever end up because this
is easy win you can't see five King C6
came over yeah so you cannot transition
into those type of engines either
okay
Play Not Afraid okay King B6 Knight D7
is what he wants
okay let's go that before now
let's go back mate does she sleep yeah
maybe not G6 96 97 before
that's the that's the best country
chance yes that's maybe reveals
well the thing is and and Anish has
drawn his game against King B6 F4 baby
that's that's his only chance exchange
pools I don't have a mate maybe maybe
not this video maybe you can just you
can just prevent
although H5 H4 yes
I don't have H4 anymore which is
annoying yeah
so let's go you invade
if you take you want to take with a
knife right
no it's going to be some sort of a race
Maybe
you start with Jesus
this way actually here really here night
before he played in G2 and 9c5 this is
I have to go to G8 right yeah 96 and
that takes A5
finish page seven
still the game
I can preserve my Pawn like this but
that doesn't look good yeah
some crazy position but okay time is
going to be a big factor right now three
minutes only 496 yes he's trying he's
just you know he's just he's trying this
he's a four as well his only chance
yeah because you know get two nights
exchanging points exchanging pools yeah
Magnus will play through Knight D3 now
stop before
because it's also time-wise not this way
it's an H5 so we could doing fine yeah
we all just you know
yes not bad not bad
um unless he sees the win but
let's see he goes for Knight C3
this is uh probably what he needs to do
if you go passive 97 this is
why I'm curious what he's going to do
all right so what if we take
I
think yeah
F4 is yeah
yeah so he took a D5 he did not no
no no no
it was a solid move yeah just to prevent
wait for it I mean force him to go H5 H4
but it's also but it's not the same
because F4 basically look he has to
exchange problems I mean this is two
nights you know they're not really good
and king is too far away yeah so when
the spools are really weak now yes and
we all know fun now he's even his stupid
Bishop is playing you were asking about
the last round where we had the five
Ross we have four so far
yeah but this is a report game you know
yes yes exactly yeah
okay I know okay he wants he wants to
win he stays now with only five
okay that's that's understand his plan
was another I think okay
interesting so I take take take
but you're probably gonna lose this
right no that's that's that's that's not
a was nice you're going to lose this
okay so he took took now we were
expecting him to take
take
let me think about
let's get used to do
if you're thinking about some F3 or yeah
but this is F6 F6 is also hanging yeah I
try to see if I can exchange pools but
this doesn't seem to me
it takes on E3 Knight takes E3 so this
is what we yeah right now
yeah five this program
only goal is to exchange fonts yeah yeah
that's that's a great thing
F5 F3 f43 just foreign
still at four yeah
take
yeah this is the key move right now
because if you allow me to stability the
king comes to that that's over for F5 he
plays it F5 and D5 F4 Knight C4 F3 these
guys are pretty good
um it's a yeah but you can hardly
imagine porn
you give them one chance and they're
gonna take it come back into the game
yeah I mean the best you have to be
perfect pretty much to win on games this
D5 D5 F4 to F4 is thinking about it yeah
yeah
Knight C4 Knight C4 F3 yeah
oh that's nice
another four
how is this
I don't know is this my best chance
maybe I don't know that's interesting
okay I'm going to give the knife for
your last Pawn right and then we're
gonna have two knights against the H bar
on age six is one
so I have to be fast four years but the
school of curious but to make this
impossible and it's just I think Craig
once did it and very very brilliantly
maneuver because it's it's it's you can
if you know the the right maneuver but
it's just it's always takes time it's
possible yeah it was King and Knight not
one that blocks the pawn and and another
it's like I think H4 was H1 still lost
H4 Knight on H3 is still lost I think
because there's this so-called line I
think it's a throat Line This is the
zoo's bones I think H4 was blocked on H3
it's still lost because Knight manages
to go to every corner so this is because
if the king ends up at the corner and
eight yeah he's still there a four dies
yes exactly yes yes this is
yeah
he has to go Knight C4
this is through the position F4 right
now
but it really doesn't much maybe you can
go Bitcoin Bishop D7 but
um
actually yeah
but it's such a big decision right you
get to this point and now you know that
F3 and then you start calculating and
you see this end game
like do you go for it or
it's the big question
it's a very interesting question
you play this position with the pawn
down I mean
you might or might not draw it but
no moves yet
before a big deal big moment big moment
hey guys
this is intense you should decide what
he does
he has to go for it yes
but the one thing about Magnus is he
welcomes this type of opportunities
Right
comes next so that's this is the Polish
he probably never played the same game
before show me the player who this
I'm pretty sure it was kayaking who did
it once you know this is this but I
don't think that you'll find many games
of grand monsters I mean and of course
over 2700 players right yeah I don't
recall any games except this one that I
saw yeah
I'm not sure but I just remember that
did you ever have it
you never had it you know it's the it's
I think once we started because in game
21 second match was carboof in Moscow
it's the uh there was a remote chance
and uh and I tried but it was very
remote actually carpool found very good
defense and it just hits the game and
the draw quickly that that Jordan
position but I was and I think I just
you know I tried to look at at the
manual and I just
did he missed no this is what we have so
King d8 first
I'm not sure why or whether it makes
sense
I don't think it makes any difference
Knight F4 is coming next move
yeah I mean what was the point why not
I don't think it was making too he's
probably trying to because if you go
maybe he was just worried about E7 but
King D7
I think maybe he wants to keep you know
the uh because of the king is seven King
takes E6 you cannot go Knight F4 anymore
seven I go King C5 let's say
and King six I go 93 normal 94. yes but
that's another story then just God knows
what happens now yeah so whether you can
just ah so he's probably trying to get
with the King maybe maybe he just wants
to keep the Knight away he doesn't work
he doesn't want to play this one the
viewers to play with okay that's that's
interesting but that's all right so
entertaining definitely it's they're
literally playing to the Lost pool yeah
yeah yeah
no that
okay King B4 King B7
so Magnus is trying to go behind to try
to get closer stop him to go to before
King is seven
he's going foreign
H5 King D4 H4
h5s
let's go H5 H4
is going for it yeah yeah
now he's looking D4 now
H4 Knight E5 King E5
so that's why King D4 now he should take
only six now
and then King history King trying to go
G1 and H3 exactly this is this the he
knows that that's a draw how do you stop
it King D4 because King goes King's
threatens to go on E5 as well
C H5 we have table base we're not being
told anything by the table okay
ah he's trying to take on G1 with the
others
that's the
link the nice together and take on G1
with the
two Knight
okay so King D4 now
the problem is you know this is the yeah
the problem is he doesn't have to take
there he what if he is just simply stays
there
okay but you might get in since one at
some point
that will go King D3 King E5 king of
five you can get five king of five can
get five
Knight F3 okay
now you cannot go you cannot go okay
king of five because Paul is hanging ah
you cannot take it no you cannot take
the pull so
okay okay now we're here
we're here okay fine
and now we're ready
oh if he wins this one that's the so how
much time left so one minute each
it's more complicated
okay can you six I think this is the
idea is you have to do what is not done
probably not Knight E5 this is King
D5 because then then as I start pushing
you
C5 okay
he wants to he wants this King to come
close to these nights yeah
okay he's probably gonna go King seven
give me five okay
yeah I don't know
we'll see
what the name game oh D7 is a little bit
dangerous because
it's not that King D5 now
ec795 that's that's how you maneuver can
be six
that's how you do that's how you do it
yeah that's how you do that
oh wow there's always there's always a
service there's always a maneuver this
is the always
no I just it's I'm pretty sure we can
look at detail with their business it's
made with spawn on H4
it's winning
I remember the line
is just an H4
actually no it says win prevented by 50
move rule so you win it in a hundred and
yeah exactly three moves yeah yeah but
this this is this but it's it's defense
there's no there's no there's no uh
here
do we have it that's right I think we do
but I'm not convinced and
we we will have to get the Arbiter to
elucidate the mystery ah by the way
that's interesting question do we have
this do I have the rule do a 50 50 moves
rules very good question no I don't I'm
not sure
we are being told that there is a 50
move rule but I'm not convinced about it
yeah
King B5 King King C5
no definitely this is more than this is
this I think at best you have 75 moves
so that's why I think that's even the
added 75 to these positions because I
think there was 75 is for rook and
Knight versus Rook yeah but I think it's
it's for the night two nights on ponsos
they I guess because I remember we have
this discussion early 90s
King D7 okay
King B6 plus this That's Mike Madness no
no no
King cc6 yeah
okay he's going towards the night huh I
don't know that's that's he he made me
wait did he just no he blew it up now
he has to be now he has to link his
Knights again
92 95 but he meant he missed he lost yes
yes
yeah
yeah 10 moves lost
D5 and you know that mvl is going to
play until he gets
one move from Checkmate and then stop
the clock and ask for the 15 move rule
or 75 move rule
okay let's go King
the five night F4
Magnus is not giving up he looked at
the crowd I I don't know what he was
expecting so maybe disappointed that he
lost
oh no he took on H4
graceful
yes he he accepted it
wow
wow okay fine okay definitely a little
entertaining thank you Gary thank you
Gary for joining us back to you in the
studio
thank you uh Christian thank you Gary
For the Love of the Game yeah Gary was
there and he just took over the show
which was great and uh well first how
many games will Magnus win today we have
a we had our viewers Paul and 33 said
that all he would win all three games
and they were wrong as we just saw a
remarkable attempt to squeeze by Magnus
and he was close he had winning
positions and interesting discussion
about the 50 move rule there I can bring
you up to date on that but we started
the show 60 of the games in day one were
all decisive but Gary came on and said
when did we ever have five drawers
commentators curse instantly uh as we
get ready for break first let's just
check in with our friends at Q Boutique
we'll do this very quickly as we have
the newest edition of the World Chess
Hall of Fame
roll the b-roll there we go uh jacket is
here and it's not to be missed jackets
are 95 polyester five percent Spandex
and feature an outstanding durable hot
press logo of the world chest Hall of
Fame on the front it is a perfect
addition to your closet makes a great
gift for those chess lovers in your life
be sure to check out cute Boutique St
louis.com for all your chestnings and as
we go on break
we're going to just do the standings
first let's see right the leaders
haven't changed yet we still have all
five draws yes
Wesley saw the one Iranian and yankov do
that lead in uh then we have MBL and
radoslav with plus one Richard with 50
and mag was still with minus one welcome
back uh Daniel uh you lost all three
games to start to day one it's nice to
see him you know just stop the bleeding
a little bit
but as we go on break we ask the players
what's it like to play in Warsaw here
are their answers we'll see on the other
side of the break
[Music]
the grandchester is back in Poland how
does it feel to be playing in the
capital city of Warsaw yeah it's very
nice to play in Poland you know I'm
getting used to it more and more which
is nice and
um yeah now I think it's even more
difficult that it was last year I mean
Magnus is playing and
and so on but um yeah very happy to be
back and also that it's that is you know
wrapping a bit and classical it's a good
feeling to be back in Warsaw I was not
there last year but the last time I was
I did win a world championship in Bridge
so it definitely feels good to come back
I'm happy to to be here I've been to
Poland a few times a beautiful city I I
think now we are located at the most
Central I've ever been located and
yeah just just you know it's really uh a
very Grand European Capital also so
clean you know yeah just a pleasure to
talk around I'm happy to be here oh it's
wonderful my mom and I definitely love
it here anymore so we were here last
year and the city is just amazing and
the people is great I'm very grateful
that there's a
a tour here in Warsaw in the part of
granchester
oh it's great I I think
the everything got better the the
weather
and also the the location of the hotel
it's much better we're right in the old
town it's so beautiful oh it yeah it
feels very nice to be back in in Warsaw
um I I just thought about it actually
recently that you know I played in
Warsaw quite a few times but I never
played classical chess always rapid
templates yeah it used to be Europeans
represent Blitz and no the Grinch's tour
so yeah kind of uh it feels like a
continuation of a cycle or something for
me
it's a new experience for me I don't
play this format before okay I will see
for me it's uh super exciting because
I'm living just here so honestly it's
there is like nothing better than it can
be
also for myself there's like zero
pressure because nobody's
expecting me to to fight for something
bigger so I can just
enjoy playing here and hopefully I will
make some nice surprises here I really
enjoy also because I was staying here
for a month during the last year travels
so I really enjoyed the city I really
enjoyed the people and as a Ukrainian
person I can say only good things about
polish nation and just about balance
it's going to be very exciting I'm
really excited to play against the best
place in the world and it's interested
to compete against them especially when
the world champion is the next I'm
playing uh rapid and Blitz here in
Warsaw for the second time and uh
in the last couple years so the first
time was the the world rapid and Blitz
Championship which didn't go so well so
I'm hoping to do better you're hoping to
do better
uh this time but but it's yeah it's nice
to be here uh feels a little bit like a
summer Vibe here already so I'm looking
forward to it
[Music]
for the first time since 2020 the
world's best female chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
San Luis Missouri for the Third Edition
of the Karens cup beginning June 3rd
players will compete for a 180 000 prize
fund
this tournament features 10 of the top
female chess players in the world
including returning Champion humpy
koneru along with top-rated American
Irina Crush
it's one of the most decisive classical
tournaments in chess that you won't want
to miss catch all the action on the
Saint Louis chess club YouTube and
twitch channels
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
following mvl and radoslavoy tashak
right fifty percent for richer report
and Magnus Carlson is still with minus
one and back then uh getting on the
scoreboard at last he started with three
losses in day one that really is hurtful
as we experienced our first five draws
as Gary Kasparov led us through the
whole and our parents were on five
all right we have two little puppies
we're just playing each other against
voice they're doing so well it's an
important game a key game mvl against
Robert and Iranian against Carlton wow
in the league but of course Carlos is
looking for that first win exactly and
Anish Geary and diach uh both in search
of the victory right and Wesley so
against
we didn't really get a chance to look at
the game between Carol and Anish from
the previous round as the Richard
Rapport game really uh well mesmerized
as all including Gary was there any win
in that whole thing I was watching
Christian and Gary analyzing VAR and it
just seemed like Richie was on the edge
of giving a Checkmate Gary was saying
take the pawn take the pawn on C5 I
think it was a draw it was just a very
spectacular what Richard did he tried
all the old ideas and but Duda found
this move King E7 at the critical moment
and it was always a draw even if he had
taken the funnels if I'm always going to
be a draw another game was interesting
we didn't see it that much was the game
between chefchenko and giri there were
missed opportunities for both players in
that game so chefchenko had a very
strong attack at some point but then he
misplayed it then Anish had some
advantage in the end game
wow okay great as we're getting uh set
up for uh this round five even though it
was five draws
very exciting and for those of you who
are joining us late shame on you but
here's our remaining schedule Ryan we
have two days of rapid and today so
please coming up and today we're seeing
rounds four five and six of the rapid
and again reminder that the Rapids are
worth twice as much as the Blitz Games
uh 18 Blitz Games nine rapid games in
these rapid and Blitz I love these
formats once again here is the program
yes you have a 10 player around Robin
and the time control in the rapid is 25
minute with 10 second increment and in
bleeds it's five minutes with two second
increment and the scoring system as the
answer mentioned in Rapid they get two
points for a win and one for a draw and
in Blitz it's the traditional scoring
system 1.4 win and a half for drop
as well once again we get ready for this
around five Magnus again he's like a
magnet that game that he just played
with mvl was remarkable because it just
felt for 40 moves it was dead dead raw
then B6 takes a five he's got some
squares and then he may be winning
material and then it's still nice versus
Pawn uh was there any winds along the
way for Magnus in that bar there was no
clear Wing but definitely uh there after
B Tech C5 which was inaccuracy by mvl
Magnus had some serious winning chances
at some point but mvl defended well this
whole idea Knight f8 96 and then playing
F4 getting some Contra player was
excellent otherwise I think he would
just slowly lose the game
safe by MBL the nice Haven uh I have
never played in my entire career two
nights versus pawn and as Gary just said
who has VAR did you ever play no no I
never had it but that one game Gary was
referring to was the game between
karyakin and actually Sam Savion
and cardiac managed to win that I don't
remember exactly where the Palm was uh
on I think it was on a fifth Rank and
then kariakin knew exactly the idea and
managed to win that end game okay I
think it was in the World Cup actually
yeah I remembered his uh Soviet books
that have been translated into English
on the on the endings over Box series
and I remember as a teenager studying
the zone of what was the winning Zone
and uh I never got it never same here
yeah never had it yeah very very uh but
now I think I'll remember that if the
pawn crosses fourth rank then it's a
draw yeah yeah there we have it although
if we were seen in table base in some
positions Magnum still had a win exactly
I think it's also important the pawn
needs to be on a or H file because if
it's closer like on G and B it's much
easier to bring the Knight for the
Checkmate because it'd be harder to
bring it to the other side so that's
actually very important exactly the
Knight is tucked away on the side of the
board so far
as again we're getting uh set up a lot
of people wrongly think that the laws of
Chess are written in stone that they
haven't changed for 500 years and in
fact they change all the time the rules
committee once you put a committee
together they can't sit still they have
to do something to justify their
existence so at one time there was
studies that showed
225 moves where you could win a knight
versus pawn it was a forced with a table
base of 225 moves so they decided to
extend the 50 move to 75. and there was
this huge outcry and the rules committee
quickly turned it back and because they
said 75 people said this was ridiculous
because of one position that nobody ever
achieves a tournament practice we're
going to change the rules of Chess and
that these rules are constantly being
changed at one time for example you were
responsible for calling your opponent's
flag the Arbiter and there was no
outside interference today the Arbiter
can call the flag so rules change all
the time
um and do you recall that whole 75 move
business yeah I thought it was pretty
funny pretty recent when they changed I
think there the player should claim
after move 50 but if he doesn't do it or
he doesn't realize at move 75 Arbiter
can step in and claim that there was no
progress made in 75 moves Ah that's for
the rules okay
um a little bit delayed um
I guess some late arriving players yes
they're pretty good at uh starting on
schedule then I guess Magnus wanted some
extra break since his game went on I I
would have thought so I I had expected
that he would say hey excuse me I just
played 100 move game or whatever it was
and again a big shout out to Gary for
spending so much time that we took a
nice nap
yeah he was fascinated by so many games
especially Richard's game yeah it was an
incredible game truly
and even in Rapid games this player is
making most precise moves
um VAR a big big game coming up Lavon
aronian versus Magnus Carlson in there
Head to Head how did the two do
28 wins for Le'Veon 45 losses and 63
draws they played each other a lot of
games in wrapping
you can you can say that again that
would be around 135 games guys right
just rapid just rapid
how is that I know the classic and Blitz
that are excluded from that stat that
you just saw so rapid chess
I mean that's that's a pretty
significant Edge I want to say for
Magnus yes sir
oh I was about to say we're going to see
a special cop for Russell limo no a
taimanov no it will happen
and
um
Lavon most of his career D4 player
wanted to make the ambidextrous move and
to become an E2 E4 player it's very very
very hard because you've got to study
the entire completely different branch
of theory but now having said that
sometimes you have what are called
natural E4 players and I for me Vichy
for example was always an E4 player he
later he played D4 and he played it very
well but he always struck me as an
outstanding E4 player has Lavon become a
naturalized
E4 player in European opinion bar
actually when I played LeBron when we
were kids you always played D4 yeah yeah
so you were used to seeing them in that
and then he made a switch about uh five
six years ago actually and just just
started to play E4 even in a candidates
tournament so it was new to him before
he just he just played it and I think
when I talked to him he told me it's
very important to play the both moves
and you see a lot of different ideas
when you play both E4 and D4 I think for
a lot of amateur players in our audience
the move Bishop C4 will come as more
than just a surprise a lot of amateur
players would have recaptured the pawn
why does white Play Bishop C4 in that
particular moment not just recapture the
pawn on D4 or Bishop C4 is the third
most popular move in this position of
course the more popular movie just
simply to recapture back when it once
you take uh pack with the pawn black can
play the bishop before check or
immediately the move D6 so Bishop C4
course now in this position and you're
threatening simply to take on D5 here
and here black needs to play the move
Knight B6 which is the main move here
now you're you're happy to sacrifice a
pawn so you play Bishop B3 and if you
take on C3 Knight takes C3 you're down
upon but you have a nice leading
development also you have a control of
the D6 Square so they're they're about
20 games played in this position and uh
looks like you know white is doing okay
in this position we do have Knight B6 on
the board so again Bishop B3 if I can
play the devil's advocate for a moment
after that position where you got your
knight to C3 so we took a pawn
black can also play the D6 in this
position just try to break the center
if you take with the queen I don't think
white is going to exchange coins so the
move like Queen E2 will be played the
idea is just simply castle and play a
quick Rook D1 Bishop F4 and why
definitely has compensation because of
the really nice lead and development for
example Knight C6 right Castle
Bishop E7 right Rook D1
and okay the best movie is Queen before
but that already looks a little bit
risky uh there are no other good squares
to go to you don't want to put it on B8
I like Queen B4 just because I see Queen
G4 and in case you know you ever get to
tickle me with an A3 right now the
bishop is hanging so it's okay I I agree
yeah the bishop D2 now uh just uh
setting up 95 and then you have to play
the move Queen G4 right and then H3
Queen H5 it's a lot of moves with the
queen but black is up upon and uh if
nothing uh dangerous happens immediately
I think black will be okay there it's a
small Plus for white in this position
after all that for those players who
enjoy playing as Scandinavian they're
used to getting their Queen bounced all
around the chessboard we do have D7 D6
on the board by the way C3
takes D4 at last Levon recaptures this
pawn and let's see yeah Gary was telling
us during his commentary that he should
always take the pawn yeah I like that I
just didn't listen he did not take it he
did not take the pun
yeah let's uh jumper okay my pick I have
to say
ah Anish come on help me out here uh
strange game going on between Anisha and
diak with this early Queen A5 it has a
name
I just forgetting this name the Czech
perk or the privilege yeah probably
check perk he actually played a lot uh
this for black but different move order
actually okay the move order I play I
can show you it actually starts off with
the move uh E4
D6 D4 Knight F6 and Knight C3 C6 right
and here F4 is the main move and then
you can play the move of Queen A5 here
and you get this position threatening 94
uh if if Knight F3 played here actually
Queen A5 is not as good because just
Bishop D2 here you play the move Bishop
G4 so you get a similar structure that
we see in the game here so this is the
check system after C6 or also called
prebill so now Knight E4 is played and
uh looks like white is better here just
needs to take on D6
and
let's see Knight takes C3 for example
and then you play the move Queen D2 this
is actually very typical if you take one
C3 you don't just capture back you play
Queen D2 because the queen on A5 is
pinned and if you just take back
you just
continue with the development you don't
need to take it immediately then you can
even Castle rookie one and black is just
in trouble here Bishop B7
Castle
let's say castle and again you don't you
don't take just play rookie one
eventually you will take back on C3 and
the white is just clearly better here
it's important to not forget to take the
Knight back exactly don't forget by the
way Richie Rapport after this uh amazing
game that he just played uh I don't know
how he's feeling but he remains his uh
challenging inventive self as he is as
saying once again a winner were French
defense uh this time with a very early
204 right Queen G4 I remember them
playing in Bucharest just a week ago and
Maxim did not get a good position right
so now he switched it up and played
Queen G4 instead exactly Queen G4 G6 H4
one of the ideas is to soften up the
king side a little bit so that this
bishop will have a nice Square H6
Queen back to D1 it looks a little
strange to go chewing and throwing but
the idea is that you've induced a hook
on the king side the pawn on H6 Queen A5
Bishop D2 Bishop D7
I think I'm more used to seeing Queen A4
immediately here Bishop D7 Knight F3 C4
A4 a very important move to rather stop
a black piece from entering A4 in a very
distant future
another reason why you want to get the
pawn off of A3 is the bishop can
relocate to the A3 Square
and we're catching up I don't know uh
VAR jump in you're a French defense
expert yourself you've played it
throughout your career where did we
leave uh the theory because we're in
novel territory aren't we yes yes we are
and I I like White's position here in
fact I've before Castle I think if he
had taken on F6 Rook F6 and then Castle
then I think white has a very
comfortable Advantage here just take
first on F6 The Rook takes F6 and Castle
because it's gonna be very hard to play
the move G5 here and your H6 spawn is
always hanging and you never want to
play the move H5 in this position so and
then slowly white will pile up with
rookie one and Bishop H3 the new idea
was the move Queen D1 in the opening
if we go back there
um that's quite some time ago yeah move
number nine yes wow this this position
it has been played about 13 games not so
many games but Queen D1 is a new move in
my database and uh
so oftentimes once you provoke
weaknesses you come back on D1 just to
make sure you're protecting your D4 and
C3 and uh with the dark Square Bishops
on the board it's actually a lot more
significant once you force the move G6
because it's going to be very hard so I
I don't really like this kind of
positions oftentimes when I'm in a
position like this I prefer the move
King f8 here just to make sure I'm
keeping control of the dark squares so
but in in a current position uh this
castling move is actually an inaccuracy
it was very important to take on F6 and
that that position is actually a very
very nice Advantage for white here but
in the game he played the the move
Castle here
very important to play this move F5
because you want to take away that
option of taking itex F6 and here at
some point you're hoping maybe you put
the Rook on G8 maybe even 98 Knight F7
and eventually play this mode G5 I think
if he plays the move F5 he is actually
doing fine in this position black should
be okay here because it's very hard to
go Bishop C1 Bishop B3 because the C3 is
hanging and by the time you play Queen
E1 Bishop C1 with P3 I think very likely
G5 move will come into play here so but
F5 move is absolutely necessary here for
black in order to equalize the position
thank you for that for in the all-polish
derby which is so crucial to our
standings I'm seeing a
an adventure some move upon sacrifice
um Carlsbad Queen Duda versus I was
going to say in a non-adventurous
opening in so yes but we're seeing early
95 yes yeah okay so it's a Carlsbad
Black Knight on A6 is not very typical
either no uh minority attack C7 C6 we do
see these Maneuvers night to see 786 but
usually there's a a dark Square mission
on G5 and this is the move that really
is uh well okay that's an eye uh
Awakening experience so you don't want
to accept upon sacrifice because I can
see if I take there is Bishop B2 and
those two Bishops will be monsters don't
be disappointed yes
it worked it work harder together I mean
it's not the training's not working but
I have a better idea for black you do I
think so sure I want to play C5 right
now right now C5 okay well if tactically
that works I think that should be good
here after C5
Okay so first impression is that Bishop
takes A6 you don't take my Bishop
because I'm assuming I'm going to get
some Advantage but you can in between
move yes yeah Swish and zubed me with
the move C5 takes D4 I always feel so
literate when I get in the switch and
zooks you know like I know what I'm
talking about C5 and if I take Knight
takes
okay so you still haven't taken my Pawn
but gosh darn it you want to take my
Bishop I don't like that I move my
Bishop
I want to sacrifice so badly with rookie
five and Bishop B5 because I don't think
it will be enough welcome I I don't
think I made any mistakes
to the point that I should be you know a
combination should punish me for my poor
play actually rookie five is very strong
is it like a very big Advantage okay 65
takes Bishop D5 and I guess I have to
play Bishop B2 just to
do some development I want to meet D4
with Rook D1 but I can imagine uh with
my king still in the center
I might even have it to Castle maybe
Queen A5 okay that's a nice tickle right
because they should be saying even more
uh annoying okay I'm in I have an idea
E4 which one
right f
E4
so maybe Knight A4 was no it was not A4
better
because I'm Knight A4 for some reason I
didn't even realize it was legal but
that is a check on C3 okay
um
if only my Bishop was developed right
Rook C8 yeah
um
sharp stuff it maybe it's still good
black it should be good I I mean this
looks really like a nasty your Rook C8
if I take on B7 Rook B8 this is a check
as well I'm not out of the woods I still
feel like uh
something could go wrong for me as black
and maybe I wow okay that is uh
uh but I wanted to ask why aren't we
taking the pawn why I mean I understand
you felt you know just your intuition is
is screaming you you know be careful
with the two Bishops you know this is
that this could be deadly
right I mean uh and I'm sad
C5 would have been very intriguing but
then again the bishop comes to B2 big
deal like big deal we we just okay go
ahead kill me do you play Rook G5 here
with black or no
I'd be tempted I'd be very tempted
provoking G3 because if I Castle we have
Bishop H3 Dan I'm a happy camper and if
you play G3 I have uh Bishop H3 as well
if you play F4 I'm kind of intrigued
like yeah I'm kind of willing to give up
an exchange because if you take maybe
you should play a rook G4 provoke H3 and
then go back
very sophisticated okay so you're
recommending Rook here upon and then go
back and maybe there's some interesting
stuff or uh
what's happening in some of our uh
leaders uh positions yeah guys let's
take a look at the Wesley's game I think
he's slightly better I like this move
before he played he has a good control
on the queen side here and now he just
played the move Knight B3 so let's see
how black can continue here so after the
move Knight B3 you have good control of
the A5 Square at some point you also
want to play the move A4 and put
pressure on B5 here so the best move
here is to cancel for shivchenko and
here the move A4 makes a lot of sense
because now you want to open up the a
file now putting pressure on V5 as well
here sure so let's say he takes on A4
you play the move Rook A4 now it's a big
Target on A6 and again white just needs
to make a couple of more consolidating
moves like Bishop E3 rook da1 and most
likely you're going to drop this A6 Pawn
here so black needs to play very active
here so Bishop B7 makes a lot of sense
developing and also putting pressure on
D5 and here in this kind of position
when we see a lot of pressure here
oftentimes we see a move like Knight D5
coming in just try to shut down that
bishop and now if you take back with the
Knight E takes D5 and again if white can
get the pawn on C4 then this bishop is
going to be really really passive for
the rest of the game so here's their
complicated lines here so you can play
the move Queen takes C2 and another
alternative is to play the move id4 so
if if you play the move Knight D4 first
Knight takes D4 he takes D4 and again
you don't have the move C4 because of
the ampassan you play the move Bishop D3
Bishop A6 and uh White is just a little
bit better here after Rook takes A6 but
I think it's not not as much here and
the other alternative instead of 94
would be actually to take the pawn on C2
and now we're putting pressure on the
Knight and now white needs to play the
only move Rook A3 and Knight is still
hanging here
so now Knight F4
Bishop takes F4 he takes F4 and
oftentimes when we have a Pawn on D5 we
want to put the Knight on A5 putting
pressure and eventually land on C6 here
so here again white is very slightly
better despite being down upon but I
think still with two Bishops black
should be able to be okay in this
position
thank you VAR uh just checking in on the
game between Levon and
um Magnus when we left it we were in
this
Lapin variation with Bishop B3 Magnus
didn't go for the pawn uh grub upon
grubber he played D7 D6 and we'll catch
up quickly to the players as they sped
their way through the same hymn book of
opening Theory Bishop C4
love that move if you if you think about
uh I love the strategy of Chess and for
me when I think strategy I think about
the pieces and what's my good piece
what's my bad piece I I present this
position to any student and I say what
is blacks good and bad pieces they're
supposed to recognize that the bishop on
C8 is passive and uh Magnus world's
number one player says well let's get
rid of it if is that if that's my bad
piece I can anchor it on D5 if you let
me so
and wow look at this Magnus sacrifice in
an exchange exactly well in our poll we
asked uh the audience how many victories
would Magnus have today a third answered
three they were wrong because we know
that in round four he made a draw but
this shows some fighting uh Chess By the
world's number one take my Rook please
absolutely yeah and I like this and I've
seen a lot of games where Magna
sacrificed The Exchange you know if he
believes in you know strength of the two
Bishops especially that Bishop on D4 is
very very strong and now he's supported
by C5 Levon did play the novelty in this
game according to my database the move
Knight E4 so maybe we can go a few moves
back to see he didn't have to give up
the pawn on D4 but he thought maybe he's
better in this position but I think the
position is very uncleish so if we go
back to this moment where we play the
move Knight E4 in this position I have
two games in a database and of course
the very logical movie is just to play
Bishop E5 here because the bishop on F6
is getting very active and putting
pressure on D4 so after Bishop E5 you
have a a very safe position but it's
about equal only but but after that
after the move Knight E4
you know inviting Bishop takes D4 and
now Bishop D6 you cannot move the Rook
because the bishop is hanging C5 is the
only move and now Bishop f8 there are
two options has been played yeah Bishop
f8 is more ambitious move he could have
also played a move Bishop takes C5 if
you wanted to go for more uh sort of
equal stable position Knight C5 but
black doesn't have any problems in this
position in fact after Queen C7 Rook fd8
maybe it's even slightly preferable to
play uh for black in this position so he
took on f8 and now we have quintex f8
and evaluation is of course zero zero
here and The Rook d8 is what Magnus
wants to play next uh pair of the
Bishops very strong uh Bishop only Force
black definitely has a full compensation
here so the materialist and the audience
say you know I've got a rook that's
worth five you got a minor piece and a
pawn that's worth four uh White's up
material but what we call comp
compensation is don't look at what Kim
off the board look at what stays on the
board and what stays on the board is
this very impressive dark squared Bishop
both Bishops are very good yes uh
eyeballing f2b2 and like you're just
saying put the bishop on D5 and both
Bishops look very good Rook to d8 on
Black's agenda uh from White's
perspective I would want to take away
the two bishops from black so I would
probably be thinking Bishop B3 myself uh
but
B2 Pawn
yeah that is uh so that would be like
two pawns and equal material for the
exchange exactly uh jumping to the game
of Wesley so because I found that whole
line what you were suggesting with A2 A4
to be so attractive but one of the
things that Wesley
does is he often comes up with similar
ideas of what you think is the main line
but a little bit offbeat he doesn't
include yeah he goes his own way uh he
does not include the move A2 A4 a move I
think everybody would find attractive he
goes immediately uh Knight to D D5 and
as you were saying VAR uh looking to
play Knight A5 in a very near future
absolutely yeah I think this is very
strong
the move Knight D5 now and uh
he he he has to play uh Queen takes C2
here in this position or for what not an
easy move to do with your King still in
the center but then you have the bishop
D3 attacking the queen yeah and uh you
have two options you can go back to C8
but then you're sacrificing an exchange
and hoping to get some compensation but
white is just better here Knight takes
eight Queen takes eight and you can just
play the move F3 now again the bishop
will go to a three Knight on A5 this is
a very nice position perhaps in this
position that's the reason why Bishop B7
move is not recommended when I was
showing you this position earlier
castling was the preferred move here for
black so Bishop B7 looks very natural
but it's an inaccuracy so now after
Knight takes D5 if you take on D5 e
takes D5 is extremely strong and you
don't have a good Square for this Knight
to go to here because if you go Knight
D4
simply capturing and after Bishop B2 the
D4 Pawn is going to fall and uh very
very big Advantage here for white and if
you decide to play the move Knight F4
here
in this position and again we will
simply take
e takes F4 and now and I can go to A5
and as I mentioned earlier the pawn on
D5 not on A5 once you put a bishop on F3
Knight goes on C6 it's going to be a
very very big Advantage for white here
all right thank you for that for uh in
the again the matchup of the two polish
leaders uh matislav and Duda
um Bishop G4 we were looking at Rook G5
and trying to make a virtue of the fact
that our Rook is a little bit vulnerable
on the diagonal let's return the favor
and go after the pawn that was not
Black's Choice Bishop G4 H3 Bishop back
92 picking up that nice Tempo Against
The Rook The Rook drop back and I
thought that this was a very Savvy move
here uh Bishop takes A6 kind of
destroying the queen side just exactly
before black gets in the moves 97 and
Bishop G6 I thought that was important
Essie and
we now have this position on the board
give me your assessment after Bishop G6
you like white like black
I think why it's slightly better yeah
we're down upon but the extra Pawn is on
A6 so I'm not worried about it that is
true and true the black Square Bishop is
just dominating the whole position so
because of that Bishop I believe white
is slightly better yeah I was thinking
uh similarly that because of the doubled
a pawns I would be looking uh to get in
the moves A5 trade off my weakness as as
soon as possible but still
um you use the word dominating that the
bishop is good it
but black is up a pawn doesn't have too
many weaknesses yeah too many weaknesses
uh again kind of his fair share of the
center fair development save King I
don't think it's that bad for black I
mean I think I would prefer to play
White too
um again let's just check in we should
look at mvl Robert because Richie just
played G5 early because Barn was telling
us to prepare a G5 was telling us to
shut things down too and play F5 and
maybe Knight d8 and he didn't do it guys
he just said he opened up the position
that's sacrifice with G5 wow okay that
is a man who is very very confident I
would be first of all a pawn down but I
would be terrified that this bishop is
actually going to dominate
um you know when we put our Bishop on F4
and our Queen on E5 we know bad thing
things happen so King B8 Queen E3 King
A8 F4
basically that move tells me that okay
I'm I'm upon up on the king side I'm
ready to play I want to create a
passport already I think so uh but more
than that he's just maybe stopping Black
from getting any play against White's
King
excuse me but
yeah I think I love to move that forward
G4 okay let's just drop that in what
else are we gonna do I mean we put our
Bishop on E8
not to
uh for nothing but
let's say I just play Rook F2
okay that that's a safe move I was even
afraid of Queen E6 Bishop C2 Queen D5
it gives back some counter play but it
might be nothing there actually it
reminds me of those puzzle Rush uh kind
of positions where you know if my if my
Bishop was on F4 I would win brilliantly
or if Rook was on B1 yeah with Queen
takes C6 okay uh but your your initial
impulse was Rook F2 right defend the
pawn on C2 uh this looks like play on
one goal to us far
absolutely guys very big Advantage for
White Years and yeah I think the idea of
not playing the move F5 was a big
mistake here because white still has the
two Bishops and uh you don't really have
that much control play here and a couple
of more consolidating moves and
eventually this if E6 Pawn is probably
going to fall and you always have to
watch out for the F5 uh you know break
as well trying to create the pass pawn
and the white king is very very safe
with the bishop on G2 doing a great job
defending against any threats so I think
technically it's winning position for
nvl but he still needs to play
accurately and by the way a big score uh
MBL uh their uh Five Points uh four
points for Richie and they're Head to
Head not as many games as between Lavon
and Magnus but pretty impressive three
wins uh for mvl against one loss right
and I think uh Wesley is doing
remarkably well in this game
which I don't blame him for it I can't
either Knight takes Pawn takes Knight F4
we saw some ideas like this before but
this whole uh concept of going Knight A5
Knight C6 putting a bishop on F3 it's so
comfortable for white it just like you
get
it's no fun chess should be fun you know
you should be having fun when you're
playing chess when you seize the
defensive and you're just holding on
grimly
white short is having fun yeah that's
not so much
was preparing a C4 break and he just
played Rook C1 very one-sided it does it
does and for Wesley what a start it's
been he had a fabulous day one came in
and finished the day as a shared first
and had a quick draw against rather slav
with his opening prep all the way until
the end game it looked like he had this
fortress on on his board at home I mean
he finished almost with the same time as
he started then for Wesley uh this is
his Road no this was yesterday he won
first game then Drew Magnus very nicely
right and then beat Richard that game do
you remember how amazing that was it was
the checkmates in the corner yes
two Queens on the board well yeah and it
was the queen f8 he found this move with
no time on his clock he played for a win
and he was rewarded
uh and he drew he's today against white
tashek yeah the everybody drew the round
four uh VAR what is caught your eye
yeah let's take a look at the
uh do that game here because you guys
were analyzing this move here at this
position in fact the move Bishop G6 was
a big inaccuracy here let me show you
why and now Duda is actually almost
winning so in this position uh
very important to play the move Rook C8
because you need to protect the C6 pawn
and tactically you're not losing the
bishop here because Bishop takes F6
there is a queen takes F6 and if you
take on H5 your Rook on A1 is hanging
because you're not canceled yet so this
move Rook C8 is very important now if
Castle
then you can play the move Bishop G6 and
white is still a little bit better
because the pawns are very weak and you
can play the move Queen A4 then Bishop
will go to D4 it's a very pleasant
position to play for white but the move
Bishop G6 immediately which you played
simply allows the smooth Queen takes C6
and the only way to get any counter play
going you have to play the move d4 but
the problem is this move is met by a
very strong Rook D1 which do the plate
and now you're likely to lose this
d-pawn and I'm about just to Castle then
I will pick up the pawn on A6 and this
is a almost plus three Advantage for
Whitefish wow wow
uh yeah the move Bishop G6 provoking
Queen takes C6 he he said take my Pawn I
dare you okay I'll take your Pawn
oh uh looks
what can I say winning uh Lavon versus
Magnus uh when we left it it was at a
material imbalance of an exchange
for great Bishops
um
queen f8 queen queen H5 a little threat
of a petite combination yeah I would be
very tempted to play G6 here but Magnus
chose H6
what do you think yeah I don't know G6
as a is almost an automatic the only
other
alternative I mean I start getting
aggressive I'm thinking F5 but I love G6
I also you know blocks the whites bishop
and C2 oh very importantly and because
I've got the dark Square bishop and I'm
covering F6 Magnus felt it wasn't
necessary to play to H6 he said give me
the pawn
Queen takes C5 A2 is hanging so Queen
takes C5 uh Magnus runs no risk Queen
takes C5 Knight takes C5 Bishop takes A2
and uh
you know four versus three uh minor
piece versus a rook especially
uh all the pawns on one side no risk but
his a pawn makes it far then he'll have
a chance to win exactly exactly all
right that's a little bit too technical
for US mvl versus Richie
uh Rook A3 okay that
uh basically mvl setting I really really
want to play Queen takes E6 but I do not
want to see Rook take pardon me Queen
takes C3 as a response so please defend
the pawn on E6 and I don't mind
temporarily misplacing my Rook Rook a
three not the first move that comes to
mind VAR yes absolutely yeah it's it's
probably not the best move uh but you
know he just wants to protect all his
pawns and again try to get the pawn only
six I prefer the move G4 which you guys
were analyzing to move G4 and then Rook
F2 and bring the Rook into the game
actually but here let's take a look how
black can respond here it's a very
difficult position and he needs to play
a move like Knight d8 which doesn't look
like a very appealing move in this
position but let's take a look
nevertheless here so 98 is the best move
because again the threat is to capture
the pawn only six so 98 trying to defend
and here again I like to move G4 it's a
good good move just to control the light
squares and if Bishop G6 played you play
the move Rook F2 protecting the C2 Pawn
your Rook is out of place for a while
but at least he's doing a good defensive
trap protecting C3 and A4 pawn and you
are still putting pressure on E6
actually but I can even play A6 despite
being down upon evaluation is not that
big here it's just less than one Pawn
Advantage for white it just shows that a
lot of this Fringe position even if
you're down a pawn but the opponent has
weaknesses it's extremely hard to break
through like you need the break here but
it's very hard to do it because the F5
move is dangerous you open up your own
king and you always have this queen side
pawns that you have to deal with so I
see some chances here for reaching this
game right thank you for that a game
that we haven't really looked at too
much is the game between Anish and and
Daniel
um it's one of those Karo Khan positions
not everybody's cup of tea but I've
always felt that the Karo Khan despite
the fact that you do give up space is
incredibly solid it's very very hard for
white to get an advantage it's a caracon
player I couldn't agree more you're
right exactly we just saw the move
Knight A4 by Anish uh probably provoking
Queen C7 again technical strategically
speaking our Bishop on C8 needs life
B6 Bishop B7 C5 is one conventional way
of trying to bring that Bishop into the
game thinking I like white space
Advantage but it's well an advantage but
not small Advantage small Advantage
there you go
and my Anish making me look bad dude he
needs to start winning yesterday I know
I know you guys are all lapping me this
is crazy and uh well
Anastasia she's a dude a defending
Champion impressive
listen
what what is this I thought we were
making that choice illegal I mean come
on he didn't hear our he didn't hear it
he didn't hear us okay very cool uh vart
what caught your eye so far uh in uh
this round five no I was also looking at
this position guys you're analyzing and
it looks like white is doing really well
in this position
and the problem is this light Square
Bishop you need a lot of moves here to
get this bishop into the game here and
like in this position specifically the
move B6 looks very interesting B6 Bishop
B7 get the bishop into the game and
eventually play the move C5 but you have
a great move Queen F3 here simply
developing the queen in this position
and making it difficult to play the move
B6 but he didn't play that he played the
move C4 actually which is which is a
good move as well and here black should
play Rook d8 try to put some pressure on
D4 and perhaps play with the idea like
Knight F5 allowing the the capture take
back with the pawn and then hopefully
lend the bishop only six and have some
counter play against the D4 Pawn it's uh
I'm always careful with the move C4 in
this position because you're never going
to have a way to protect the D4 Pawn
anymore with with the pawn but uh you
know he's trying to grab a space in this
position so that's the reason he played
this move so both moves Knight F5 or
Rook d8 are playable for black a slight
Advantage here for white in this
position
um
I jumped to do the white hash X game
there is a very
critical moment in the position right
now I was looking if white can just take
Bishop takes D4 in this kind of position
yeah and then I noticed F4 is hanging
yes we can pull up the analysis board
okay so this is the current position and
wow you you are you're pointing at this
this shift takes go ahead queen queen
takes up four taking advantage of the
nice pin and queen takes C8 uh that's
what we call a surprise of a rossing and
Dutch queen takes C8 row if I have to
take the queen I take your queen and in
the meanwhile I'm an exchange up is that
the end of the story though you can play
Queen E4 white is winning but yeah you
can play Queen E4 Queen C7
now needs to be played Queen takes G2
and queen H2
a kind of a okay you know it's funny
because the engines will immediately
tell us why it's winning because they
that they're cold-blooded they don't
they don't see that after Queen F3
there's still awkwardnesses of light
squares and checkmates and so on so they
they think uh and wins I think for a lot
of us we would be a you know like is it
so clear we would be a little bit uh
it's actually a funny movie here
yesterday after Queen F3 the best movie
is just Castle
oh we can still do that
I remember uh
very Victor coach now told me the story
that
he had such a position and he went to
the Arbiter
beforehand and he said I want a castle
even though my Rook is attacked can I do
that
the governor said yes
okay and in that line in that line is
actually a very important detail uh if
you cancel yes uh the move Bishop E4
looks really strong it looks like you
cannot move anything in this position so
I will show you uh and it looks like at
some point Rook lift will come and
you're gonna give me but you get made it
but the problem here is the movie Bishop
takes F6 and when you take back Queen C3
comes in with the check and this is a
very important detail otherwise uh King
h8 Rook G8 is just simply going to get
mated right so but we have a different
move guys play The Rook takes D4 plate
and this is not the best thing F4 by the
way this is not the best move still um
Advantage still Advantage Advantage for
why but now Queen C2 is the best move
here to try to create some Contra play
can I play Queen E2 yes Queen E2 and
then
black will play the move Knight E4
and if you exchange Rook C2 is very
strong
you're getting uh and we're two points
castle and if you're Castle then I can
capture only two and after Rook C2 we
have the both pieces hanging so on some
Dynamics actually black has uh some
Contra plays still yes for two pawns
yeah okay uh Wesley uh Wes when we left
it we kind of like this position how's
he doing now uh it's changed a bit but I
think he's still doing quite well he's
still doing quite well Rook takes C4
Queen B6 uh he slurped upon off the
board rookie four
okay
he's he's almost got his grippers on uh
you know he he's he's gonna go Knight A5
Knight C6 is if he can get his you make
that transfer life is going to be very
good King f8
Bishop F1
G6 okay I'm getting confused now Knight
A5 looks good for Wesley yes G6 was a
very slow G6 and yeah he had to play uh
Rook takes E4 in this position sure
Queen takes E4
and then play the move Rook E8
uh it's very important to try to get a
contra play quickly before a white can
consolidate and protect and if you take
I think just Queen takes B4 and very
important that the Evon square is
covered so you never have that rookie
one check yeah I I it's always tough to
give give up your Pawn Shield near to
your king even though you're making a
active play for black uh not an easy
decision there for Carol uh so he did
play the move G7 G6 but that Tempo makes
all the difference in the world because
again uh Knight's coming to C6 and or
you're taking
um Advantage Wesley
I'm going to go mvl versus uh Richie
because things keep changing every time
I think mvl is you know Landing well
Rook F2 and we've seen this G4 move
um thing shift Bishop F7 not the move
Knight d8 but uh Richie's saying okay
this is just temporary I'm eventually
going to get my Bishop to a good Square
Rook B1
rookie eight Rook D5 Queen C7
a lot of chewing and throwing but
Richie's getting
so if I play Rook B1 now attacking B7
okay I'm not a I'm I'm not a big fan of
playing the movie B6 and I don't think I
want to play the two Rooks versus the
queen because I have pawns on the king
side yeah so I will play B6 uh
recognizing fully that uh
hmm I've got issues uh on on the long
diagonal but for the moment
c2's hanging and also you have a queen
H7 idea which is very important to get
control play thank you for that for I I
completely miss queen in fact you can
play it before B6 it's a possibility as
well here inviting inviting groups yes
if I take check
and the King if you put your King on F1
Bishop takes C2 and Bishop D3 might be
awkward I don't know
you play King F2 though
uh so I took the point on B7 but there
is no follow-up it's just the pawn that
I took I actually think what Richie did
is very clever he lured mvl with his
Rooks on that side of the board but
you're not really going to have a
breakthrough there we know how solid
these positions are for black and now
suddenly he's actually going to get a
contra play on an H file with this queen
H7 move so I think this the whole plan
with Rook A3 uh originally when he
started with and now bring the other
Rook it's I think gonna backfire here
and by the way uh mvl recognizing the
Queen Seven held
promise along the H file played Bishop
H4 let me just uh refresh my board
because we have a couple of moves on the
board and reaches looking
confident
well ever since he played G5 a move that
we actually didn't like he has been
playing very confidently and he's just
played the move Queen D3 inviting Queen
takes D3 and guess what CJ C3 and that
is a very very powerful past Pawn so
he's about to pick up the exchange right
Bishop B1 indeed um
yeah
and because of our standings this is a
huge game now see right MBL is only one
point behind the leaders so it's a very
important game and however if Richie
wins this he will also jump and drive uh
trampoline again at the Double score 2.0
for a win in the rapids one point for a
win in the The Blitz conventional
scoring system for Blitz not so for
Rapids
um Queen E1 we're seeing exchange
sacrifices all over the board bar what's
going on yes it's it's still a little
bit complicated reach is better already
he made a lot of progress and he should
just take on B1 and now very important
move uh to play because you really want
to play the move Rook B8 to trade that
last rook and neutralize the pressure
but the problem is E6 spawn is hanging
right so that's why after he takes on B1
he should play the move Queen F5 after
that so I will show some of the lines
now so we should be one Rook B1 Queen F5
now Queen is actually very well placed
here you're protecting E6 at some point
you're also looking at possibilities
with the Rook takes H4 sacrifice so
always now white needs to watch out for
that one thing you have to be very
careful you don't want to allow this G2
Bishop to get open at some point so
that's why it's very important to secure
the E6 spawn in this position and here
it's actually very difficult position
like King H2 is the best move for white
but I think it's very hard to play a
move like this just put your King on the
H file but the point is you want to try
to get a contra play with the move
Bishop H3 here
so another idea he can try is to play
the move Rook B5 here which is I think
maybe more logical but then even the
move A6 is is good for black because now
you're attacking the rook and if you
play the move Rook C5
King goes to B7
these Bishops are not really well placed
they're not really helping the attack
here you do have you don't have any ways
to activate the queen B1 score is
covered and yeah black can even consider
some moves like King C7 Rook B8 and Rook
B1 so this is very very nice advantage
for black here so King H2 will be the
best move here to try to play the move
Bishop H3 in that case black plays the
move Knight E7
and if you play the move Bishop HD that
allows the move Quincy to check now
by the way we have our first result in
round five livon and Magnus have drawn
their game
what is it expected I think well it was
like two pawns for an exchange and the
players found a repetition for Magnus uh
still hasn't found
yeah five rounds into the rapid and uh
well our world's number one uh losing a
lot of rating points I must say as it
goes on uh Daniel uh
bad start very bad start but what's
really going on and it's kind of a
continuation from Bucharest they moved
to Warsaw time his mismanagement
in the first half of Bucharest was
terrible yeah he's playing this game
with 30 seconds on the clock it's still
very early in the game Manish has seven
minutes on him and his position is
unpleasant too exactly the double pawns
at first blush you think okay I could
put the bishop on E6 look a little bit
deeper you see the night kids go can go
to F4 as well as the C5 the bishop is
not going to be stable on the E6 Square
just
clean Advantage for for Anish maybe his
best position in the tournament thus far
so far yes yeah and we see Knight
honesty definitely going to try to press
and convert this absolutely uh again
let's just check in on
uh Duda and radislav when we left it
Rook takes D4 missing that Queen take C8
that's a sweet little uh tactic uh Queen
E2 what we saw 94 okay we've got thing
we're getting play for the two pawns
Rook to D1
and now black has to find the incredible
move Bishop takes H5
takes or just Bishop H box page five
immediately
I heard Texas
okay Bishop H5 that's a visual Queen
takes H5 Queen takes F2 Checkmate we get
that Knight takes H5 and now we
understand the second Queen takes and
Shack and we start to get that as well
F2 is weak and we've got Play Bishop H5
very visual
I'd be attracted to it but maybe I
wouldn't play it because of G4
would you I mean you see Bishop H5 and
you think oh well that's really great
then you go oh are you just gonna play
G4 and I'm gonna have to go back are are
we satisfied but apparently G4 really
weakens the position and after the move
Bishop G6 despite being two pawns down I
think black has uh you know pretty
strong Contra play here again I I'm not
disputing that I'm just saying that uh
you know you you have to imagine that
your opponents played G4 and you've lost
two Tempe and you're thinking to
yourself uh I can't I've got to do
something now and I can understand why
Queen B3 was played yes he wants to play
Rook suit too right absolutely dude are
just castled like because I'm guessing
he has something after Roxy too Queen
b45
now dude is just completely winning guys
two extra pawns Queen B5 that's a huge
tempo maybe he is oh I think he missed
it
well instantly comes Queen B5
and now black has to defend the rook and
white can just play Bishop D4 and that's
that's sayonara I can't play can't play
King f8 Bishop takes G7 deflection uh
that's a that's a pretty pretty
tactic deflecting the king away from the
protection
um yeah and if we move our Rook then
simply Bishop D4 I think as you were
about to explain Nasi uh that's two
extra pawns and happiness happiness all
around so Duda defending Champion
looking
very very good I think at the moment the
only other player who can catch him is
Wesley all right he's also winning oh
well let's check in on Wesley
if they both win they'll be co-leaders
of the tournament all right we left it
more or less around these parts Rook C8
okay a2a3 just defending the pawn on B4
again
the possibilities of Knight C6 Knight
takes B7 are not going away munch munch
Rook C3
that's not really a tickle because of
Knight C4 Queen
check
picked up page seven Pawn You Gotta Love
Wesley
gotta send him his uh Pawn Brothers uh
Gold Card uh Queen H4 G5 and we're up to
date with the players and Wesley is like
to give up hey man how many pawns do you
want to give me sure you can have F2 but
I've got G2 covered a bit concerned
though let's say queen up two all right
let's do it King H1 and Bishop D4 okay
can you get away with Bishop to D4 you
do have a big threat on me but okay I
guess I can
um
I again I've got G2 covered a couple of
ways the bishop as well as the queen and
I'm lucky three
can I take your Rook
check
yes you can
wait wait it's not over Bishop takes D5
it is not over
hello
good morning
yeah no good morning St Louis black is
winning that oh my sorry I was being a
little bit yeah you need to play I think
Queen G3 here yeah I was being a little
bit because uh if you exchange Queens
the rookie thing and the bishop on V7
still oh Bishop's Hangout
s
B7 and okay so Wesley saying you you you
have some counter Spiel on F2 but I've
got it under control
because Knight takes B7 is on White's
agenda
um looks good for Wesley so our two
tournament leaders
and by the way just jumping back to Duda
just for a moment because I'm told this
queen of two check on the board Bishop
D4 as long as Wesley plays Queen Bishop
D3 and then yeah
um dude is down on time as is dioc but
what is happening
hold on we saw Bishop D4 we didn't Pawn
um it's okay we can we can get it back
we can take a seven Pawn right a little
bit of two queen D1 which is I think
already on the board Rook F1 and next
move uh we are on the game between uh
Duda and radislav Rook takes F2 Rook
takes F2 Queen takes D1 check
on the board as we can see uh players
there tell me the clock times again uh
dude is playing with 20 seconds and
increment right really okay my tashek
has three minutes uh Rook F1 Queen C2 so
increments for Duda even though he's
materially speaking winning second right
now on the board eight seconds five four
wow
takes on G6 you got to go H takes G6 no
choice there he's trying to simplify the
position of course because he's so long
time well give me a check maybe one I'll
simplify both of our lives uh with a
thread of Maintenance one
but he might be given
away some of his Advantage let's say I
can play F6 here it's forced I have for
you to play right at night F6 so F6 but
tell me how I'm giving up age seven that
was what I wanted I was thinking that
Rook F4 uh Jennifer shahadi's favorite
Rover Rook up and over uh can I play
Knight G3
because I have Perpetual ready if you go
G4 no I was going to go Knight H5 okay
so finally I've chased your knight to
the
infundibulum and maybe I can take upon
we do have F6 Queen D5 not Queen E6
check which I played but uh Queen D5
check may be a better centralizing move
keeping an eye on the Knight
would you play Rook F7 here I really
think I hate to put it myself in a bit
but I would really be thinking about it
because I'd be a little bit afraid of
King H7 Rook F4 and okay I get my knight
here but maybe it's stuck
uh be a little bit afraid uh VAR Jump
Right In Queen E6 check or queen D5
check which was the better move uh Queen
D5 check was played was that the the the
the nice choice I think both moves are
good here Queen E6 was a little bit more
natural but I want to go maybe just a
few moves back here where Duda was just
could have won the game actually really
so I can show you the key difference
here in this position so if we go back
just a few moves here after the move
Rook takes F2
uh he played in this position he played
Rook takes F2 it's still winning but I
think it's more important it's important
to start with the move Knight takes G6
first
and now if you take back with the H Pawn
he still plays the move Queen E5 and now
Rook takes F1 Rook takes F1 and if you
play the move F6 you're dropping your
knight and if you go back Knight F6 then
you're gonna lose to the move Rook takes
F6 but in the game we got the same
position the queen was already on C2 so
he could play the move F6 so that that
is the big difference in this position
wow and I'm just uh they are despite his
massive time disadvantages turning the
position around Anish Geary put a lot of
emphasis on his pass Pawn on C6 and it's
firmly blockaded black is doing great
Daniel's King is going to be coming to
the D6 Square A5 is hanging
my my pick is really uh suffering but
I quickly jumps MBL rapper Game because
I don't know what's going on dude I need
help
who is playing for a win I guess
returned well he did go for that Rook C5
idea mentioned but Rook B8 threatening
Rook B1 mbl's King is a little bit uh
just made his last move with two seconds
on the clock who did Richie no way
really Rook takes F4 well I think
yes I I can't calculate I stopped and I
think it's a repetition Richie was
completely winning guys and um he just
made a few mistakes at the very end the
last move Knight takes D4 if we go back
there he had to move just Rook B3 there
and picking up the C3 Pawn with a check
King H3
B3 oh that is so simple Rook take C3 as
well as Knight takes defense
that is just you have no time on the
clock exactly as Marie says you know
time travel makes fools of us all and
that is so true Rook B3 and easy an easy
a win missed by Richie by the way what's
happening we're getting draws across the
board we had a 60 decisive results
we jinxed it we were much happy and uh
again Richie having no time
mdl having four minutes and with no time
on his clock he decided to go for the
repetition
he took Knight xd4 and probably
overlooked the move Queen takes C4
and and that you cannot capture back
because of the pin on the king what is
happening in the all-polish game Duda
White tashek
let's do it because they're both in
time trouble
and as I said that white hashek just
made move on one second one second yeah
but somehow he's managed to maintain his
Knight on e4 which is giving him
countries to have at least Perpetual
right exactly and there's Knight D2 as
well maybe not Queen G4 was played on
id2 Knight D2 as well as a different
perpet I want to say Perpetual no says
Duda I don't want to allow check and I
will play H4
but oh wait there's Queen F4 Now isn't
that winning
a huge blunder now Queen F4 is winning
Queen F4 winners I just pushed six take
a seven
you're absolutely right Queen F4 check
and radislav immediately recognized it
when he played G5 takes H4 as this minor
piece end game is play on one goal C6
passer as well as Bishop A7 what you
were saying now see and our tournament
leader Duda is in cruise control yes
I mean maybe he had quite a number of
slips but he rided the ship at the end
there VAR absolutely yeah missed the
easy draw he should have just played the
move Knight F1 check instead of taking
on H4 and I think he just simply
overlooked the exchange of the queens
and now Bishop is very strong A7 Pawn is
gonna fall as well here now Knight F1
check King H3 walks into bad news Queen
G1 and Bishop C5 nice move to cut cut
off the squares and there we saw the
handshake that wins well if I know we've
got a win I mean our first win it took
us a while but uh Duda broke through uh
go ahead sorry and what why did okay we
agree G5 takes H4 was a game loser of
our he had to play Knight f one check
and why is that a draw Knight F1 check
is a drop because if you go to H1 I just
have a knight G3 that's clear yeah and
if you go back to H3 is simply Queen G1
move now you're threatening mate on H2
and we take with the check just take
back with the pawn and we make love for
our King
just I think just you don't have a way
to escape King H7 King H7
G6 also looked good so the king can go
farther than G4 nice okay let's go uh
we've got two games remaining we have
Anish Gary versus Daniel and Wesley so
let's go with the Wesley so because
that's such a crucial game for our
tournament standings Wesley on the white
side he's got one two three pawns he's a
pawn up
um not easy to convert this why
um
active Rook but I've got this great
night and it's uh it's I'm menacing the
F7 but I don't like your double pawns on
the king side you don't I love my extra
Pawn on the case at some point maybe
black can just sacrifice
okay is this where we pounce Rook takes
F7 Munch Bishop C5
probably
uh what's the times of the players 12
seconds for our Niche and 24 Carol for
Wesley oh sorry Wesley yeah
um uh Rook
ooh Rook G4 rookie one he's missed Rook
E8 Wesley's so tactically alert
perfectly timed his opponent as Daniel
diach did Daniel win your wins oh my
gosh
yeah his first game our congratulations
to Daniel but I'm what happened to
anishi was undefeated it's like a
different player in this tournament yeah
sir what happened very different
um King h8 this bishop E4 check is that
it take a four also a very good move
right
threatening the bishop threatening FM
oh my gosh that's like a triple Whammy
triple
attack yes yes Knight F6
you hit the bishop and that's a
resignation oh my gosh Rook takes G4 was
a game losing blunder and we had two
drawings but we're back to our 60 yeah
three ways as these last three games
Wesley so Duda are uh co-leading
yes I think earlier Levon was also in
the lead but he drew his game he did so
now Judah and Wesley in clearlit
um
I was saying I like I I believed in
Wesley yeah maybe you were saying no uh
it was that move Rook takes G4 that
blundered everything VAR absolutely Rook
G4 is a huge blunder I think black is
probably holding this position if he
plays this correctly yeah so I can show
you what he had to do in this position
that's Daniel's game yeah let me get to
that game so
uh as you pull up your board let's just
go to uh Warsaw uh with Christian for
view from Warsaw
speaking of that game guys let's take a
look at how the players got to that
final position because it was a roller
coaster and I have to say Wesley did get
a great position out of the opening
definitely understood the opening phase
much better than his opponent but after
that he slipped let's take a look at the
critical moments so Wesley started with
this bishop to B5 Sicilian D4 and queen
takes D4 we've seen A4 as well from the
white side in certain games I think
Richie Rapport play at that position but
it was a completely different approach
much more strategical approach coming
from Wesley and I think he knew what
he's doing Queen to E3 take a look at
this queen and see where it lands in a
few moves Queen to E3 Knight to C3
Knight to G4 targeting the queen Knight
goes back to F6 but now I can defend
well actually you're not even attacking
this Pawn on e4 because if you take it
take take Queen to E3 then you're kind
of in trouble Knight to C5 is no longer
possible because with the Rook already
on D1 I have ideas of just simply taking
on E5 and with the e-file opening up
you're going to get destroyed in the
center so a bishop to E7 Queen to E1
very nice move Queen to C7 Knight to D2
and Wesley was really building a nice
strategical Advantage B4 this Knight
landing on A5 very nice Outpost for the
night but unfortunately for him despite
the fact of getting a winning position
take a look at what happened later on in
the game this was the critical moment
take take we see a lot of exchanges
Wesley definitely building up I think at
this point Yasser was mentioning hey how
many pawns are you giving me
um with the black pieces and Wesley was
taking all the pawns that his opponent
was throwing at him but this was a
critical moment Queen to G3 take on G3
and Rook to C7 at this point Wesley had
the opportunity of just pretty much
ending the game with the move Knight
takes B7 Rook takes B7 Bishop takes A6
he saw Rook to A7 and he understood that
if he withdraws with the bishop Rook
takes A3 and that's most likely going to
be some sort of a draw but
check this internet so out Rook to D3
attacking the bishop on E3 and defending
the pawn on A3 at the same time this
would have been just simply winning for
um Wesley he did not play that he played
the move Bishop to F5 and gave his
opponent chances but unfortunately for
kiril he was unable to use his chances
and equalize the game Wesley so takes
down
um kiril chefchenko and continues in the
lead of course in the cold lead position
with uh Duda who won his game against uh
radoslavoit but take a look at this game
between Levon and Magnus because you
guys didn't cover it too extensively
this was an easy draw for Magnus and
we've seen this from Magnus with the
black pieces with the exception of that
first game in which he has said the
Polish opening in Poland well that was a
disaster but with the exception of that
one he's been equalizing uh effortlessly
out of the opening with the black pieces
and this game illustrates that as well
take a look at this he knows the opening
he's playing fast he's putting a lot of
pressure on his opponents Bishop to C4
Bishop takes D4 sure that's an exchange
sacrifice but unfortunately for white I
have the two Bishops and I'm controlling
the whole board and you're not going to
be able to take advantage of this
exchange sacrifice the transition into
an end game in which sure white has a
slight Advantage but it just simply is
not enough and the game petered out into
a draw quite quickly after that good
effort by Levon but he was definitely
outranked in the opening phase Magnus
knew the opening equalized with the
black pieces and right now going into
the final round of the day he will have
the white pieces and he will be trying
to win this one guys exciting just
coming in around six from Warsaw Poland
back to you in the city thank you
Christian now we we allowed our heroes
for their great preparation but
sometimes we get it completely wrong
through the magic of television then
we're gonna go back to the pre round
four situation as Richard Rapport
boldly strolls into the playing Hall and
is looking at this looking at the name
plates and it's quite clear that he
prepared for the wrong opponent and he's
laughing about about it as he he looked
like five times at the name played of
his opponent he was playing the
tournament leader Duda Duda came
completely unprepared and now look at
him it's sort of like oh my god what
have I been doing this whole morning I I
just spent the last two hours preparing
for VAR and I should have been playing
preparing for uh how hilarious is that I
have actually done that once in my
career it was so embarrassing our
standings all right we have two leaders
now Wesley saw and young Christoph Duda
they're very impressive leaders too I
must say closely following livon aronian
and one point behind Maxi Michelle Graff
then with 50 we have Richard Rockford
and radoslavoy tashek imagine Wisconsin
still standing with minus one and my
pick Anish Gary Come on having a bad
tournament let's do it as we prepare for
our parade as well our last uh our last
uh round coming up but before we go on a
break
we've got a happy birthday
happy birthday will of our production
team there we go love the sweater will
okay happy birthday will
wow just a very youthful 60.
we'll take a break and we'll see you on
the other side see you soon
[Music]
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year
for the first time since 2020 the Cairns
cup is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back the
summer chess classic August 2nd followed
up with the St Louis Norm Invitational
and the winter chess classic wraps up
the year in December September brings
back everyone's favorite chess night LX
where some of the world's best don't
even know what's coming and compete for
a 150 000 prize fund 30 players across
three Fields come together in St Louis
for the U.S juniors girls and Senior
championships starting July 15th in
partnership with us chess the best in
the U.S fight to be the nation's best
and a four hundred thousand dollar prize
fund in October as the U.S and U.S
women's championships takes place in the
chess capital of America a year full of
action-packed
just getting started all broadcasts are
available on our St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch.tv channels
for the first time since 2020 the
world's best female chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
San Luis Missouri for the Third Edition
of the Karens cup beginning June 3rd
players will compete for a 180 000 prize
fund
this tournament features 10 of the top
female chess players in the world
including returning Champion humpy
koneru along with top-rated American
Irina Crush
it's one of the most decisive classical
tournaments in chess that you won't want
to miss catch all the action on the San
Luis chess club YouTube and twitch
channels
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and here we are in Warsaw I was walking
around and I was checking the fan Zone
and there were many people playing chess
today there are tournaments every day
many people are also in the plane venue
and it was really nice to see former
world champion Gary Kasparov discussing
his the game between Magnus Carlson and
Gabrielle they were talking in the
playing in the players area and it was
nice to see them you know analyzing all
these games blindly and I just wonder if
people can really understand what they
were talking about I published this
video in our social media in Instagram
account so please subscribe to our
social media accounts so don't forget to
follow grandchester or Instagram Twitter
and Facebook and then you will find lots
of materials there as well backstage
materials and I'm here for you to
deliver all those kind of interesting
information so now we're coming back to
the studio because the sixth round of
the second day is about to start
Anastasia thank you so much for that and
uh for us as we prepare for our last
round of the day let's just take a quick
look at the standings we have two
leaders Wesley soy and young Christoph
Tuda and I've got big news
the pairing is going to impressed go
ahead uh we have close the following
livon aronia and Maxima Sheila Graf with
50 Richard Robert and radoslavoid hashek
and Magnus still with minus one
absolutely Richie is playing a roller
coaster of a tournament he could have a
lot more points and out pairings as we
go into this round six and we're going
to see a big one at the very bottom of
that list
so we have Carlson against Gary Rapport
against Iranian that's an important
matchup for sure MBL right chefchenko
diyak and the two leaders playing each
other once we saw against Judo what a
way to finish the second day of the
Rapids and I gotta ask you and their
head-to-head matchups Wesley and uh and
do to do bar 15 wins for Wesley four
losses and eight draws he has been
dominant in their matchup that's almost
an adoption that is huge why is someone
signed it
I mean Wesley is just so strong in this
formats rapid and Blitz especially he's
just so so strong so intuitive
as we just saw in his game with Carol
the moment we saw that move Rook takes
G4 Wesley
virtually without thinking rookie one
right and it just it kills on the spot
he's tactically
very very aware isn't he just sees those
those moments very sharp yeah as we get
to set up for this round six our final
round of today we've played three rapid
games today we'll play three more rapid
games tomorrow and then we go to the
blitz do you have the feeling that
Magnus just wants to get the rapid out
of the way
you can get to the blitz no I think he
wants to get a win first
right yeah to give himself a chance as
far as I know Anish is uncomfortable
opponent for him I know he has lost to
him in classical term classical time
control exactly and anisha's having a
really tough tournament truly so Magnus
will definitely try to
right and and they're head to head and
Rapid chest uh almost to three to one
advantage in favor of Magnus uh and so
many games so many boy 45 draws so you
so saw that uh graph well the the camera
on his Fury where he kind of put his
head in his hand and he looked down he
said well with my 45 bras what did I do
that was right yeah right what was I
doing that was right
and Magnus seems to be on the verge of
winning a game bar but somehow coming up
short yeah he's getting close and I
think uh this might be an opportunity an
issue is definitely struggling so far
and Magnus got the white pieces so I
think he's definitely going to try to
push pretty hard in this game
we might backfire
and we heard a little bell there as we
see our two tournament co-leaders Wesley
and aduda we'll keep an eye as
runs underway
and we have petroff Petra so there we
see the Styles uh the night the White
Knight looking sideways the Black Knight
looking ahead yeah two different Flyers
right
now uh Wesley uh having worked so hard
on E4 E5 is aware of the problems of the
white players hey having against the
Petrov and I know that Wesley has played
Knight D3 and other weird moves he's one
of those players with the white pieces
that doesn't seem to have anything
special
um VAR against the Petrov yeah Petrov is
very very tough to break I I expect he
wouldn't take so many chances Wesley he
he's got a nice lead and you definitely
don't want to lose to the guy that you
shared the lid with right with the white
piece so he will try to get something
very small and most likely play for two
results in this game
can we jump to magnus's game because as
the it's a theory in the Petrov we can I
think you're going to enjoy the opening
he just
yes sir
uh
the crazy part is this move Bishop A3 is
not a novelty that's the crazy part I
see that it's still been on my database
Bishop okay uh the Larson opening
um Queen side fee and Shadow B3 but
Bishop A3 now we're a novel territory
the moment we saw Knight D7 uh
VAR you're a resident expert
what do you have to say about them
apples yeah let's take a look definitely
97 was the new move in that position I
have 20 games in a database and everyone
played the move Knight F6 in this
position after the move Bishop A3 but
let's take a look at the current
position guys so
he played the move 97. C4 makes a lot of
sense to put pressure on D5 and the main
idea of the move Bishop Patrice just to
make it more difficult for black to play
E6 or even if you play six after
capturing on f8 which we will see in the
game you have to take back with the
Knight and waste couple of more tempos
before you can cancel so E6 was played
by Anish there is no good way to really
protect this D5 Pawn if you take on C4
then you're exchanging your Central Pawn
for a Pawn on the side and white will
have a control of the center after
Knight c3d4 so that's why E3 is the best
move you don't really want to play the
move C6 in this position because after
CD the the Knight on D7 is not very well
placed here you will Knight on C6 but in
the current position after E6 he took on
f8 Knight takes f8 and the play the move
the D3 this is logical because the
bishop is only five you want to put the
pawn on D3 to blockade it Knight F6 and
G3 so very slow setup he wants to go
Bishop G2 castle and then decide where
to put the Knight Knight C3 or 92.
clearly there is no Advantage here for
white and and you can't really obtain an
advantage by playing B3 Bishop B3 but at
least it's you know new territory and
he's hoping to outlay on each later on
in the middle game I think Matthews was
on a mission to just exchange black
Square missions
accomplished uh turning our attention to
Richie report because it would not have
escaped lavon's notice that in this
Vienna Queen F3 had been played by
Richie that's uh that crazy game earlier
in the earlier today with Duda Queen F3
Knight C6 Bishop B5 and check out Lavon
he came prepped with Queen H4 check
and we're not up to date with the
players yet Bishop D7 gift meet the pawn
I want to play Knight takes E5 what are
you gonna do about it I'm gonna take
your knight
in Bishop E3 and wow last move I guess
up to this moment VAR We are following
uh the
the precepts of opening Theory and the
moment B6 appeared all my database went
away what's going on absolutely same for
me after B6 I don't see any more games
played uh instead of B6 the black played
a few different moves in that position
played the move G6 couple of times H5
was even played with the idea to play H4
and of course Bishop p7 but only a few
games in a database B6 is a it's a very
logical move because you wanna blockade
a diagonal of the bishop and it's a very
possible they won't analyze this
position so with two Bishops on the
board uh I think very important to
Castle now for white to try to
discourage black from castling and there
is definitely a setup that Lebon
analyzed here because it's not so simple
to play so Bishop E7 perhaps it will
play
and now Knight wants to land on F5 so
this needs to be prevented so you need
to play the move Bishop D7 okay and uh
Rook hf1 it's it's really hard to see
how white will have an advantage in this
position so Bishop H3 now attacking The
Rook Rook F2 perhaps and now eventually
Castle black should be fine in this
position and it also has the two Bishops
and even if you lose the E4 Pawn still
you will have a pretty good compensation
here so I don't think any opening
problems Levon has here sorry that last
move Rook uh F2 if we had played Rook at
four uh or just that last move uh I
didn't yet that one yeah Rook F4
actually you could lose the exchange
after Bishop G5 and Knight B5
Knight B5 here okay just just to point
out if you take this yeah I saw that one
yeah a knight B5 yeah and now I think
just uh simply just Castle
Rook is still hanging and if Rook takes
E4 yeah Bishop G2 will be played here
black is very slightly better in this
position but white has some compensation
for the exchange well I'll get a couple
of pawns for sure the the one on e4 and
C7 intriguing stuff going on here again
just want to check in on our tournament
leaders Wesley so versus Duda uh all
very very theoretical uh
the Petrov Knight D7 Knight D6
um really I'm gonna I want to blame nepo
for really popularizing it the Petrov
amongst the modern day uh
E4 E5 crowd as Bishop f8 on the board uh
all my all the games of my database VAR
disappeared I don't know where the
novelty came yeah one thing I wanted to
mention if we go back to the move B3 in
this position this Wesley had this
position with the black piece it's
actually against Hans Neiman in 2022 and
he won with the black pieces in the U.S
championships
Championship or single single cup one of
these two tournaments so after the B3 in
that game 96 was played so rookie 8 is
the new move here by Doda we actually
played the move 96 and I remember that
was a very solid game and I think Hans
overpressed and lost so rookie 8 now is
the new move and now we have C4 pulling
pressure that's the main idea of the B3
to try to play C4 to try to apply some
pressure on the fire because otherwise
the structure is so symmetrical it's
going to be very hard to create any any
winning chances so now Bishop f8 played
and the black just puts the bishop on f8
the solid Square opening up the file for
The Rook very small Plus for white in
this position move H4 is interesting to
try to play H5 and also get the Knight
on G5 so this is one alternative another
option is just simply to take on D5
black probably should just trade the
knights Knight takes D5 Knight takes D5
CD and here the Knight is doing a great
job on D6 and has an opportunity now to
go to E4 so it's important to eliminate
the Knight with Bishop takes D6
and now if Queen takes these six
you can play this position with the G3
and claim a slightly better position
because D5 Pawn is a little bit weak
because you're not going to have much
help with the Ducks for Bishop to defend
it very very small plus here for white
in this position thank you for that uh
some players are just natural born
Sicilian players they love playing the
black side of the Sicilian a kind of a
counter uh attacking
variation well Carol says
I want to play Sicilian but with the
white pieces so give me an extra Tempo
in this game against dioc it really does
look like a colors reversed type of
situation going on whether or not
reverse neither for yeah with a bowl of
sloths he reverse night night or whether
white gets an edge by having an extra
move in Sicilian well that's a question
I think black is doing just fine in this
position let's again check in on Magnus
and Anish Gary the move Bishop A3 I
remember having in the 1978 uh world
junior Championship one of my opponents
had played an early B3 Bishop A3 and
let's see how I Niche handled this the
dark Square Bishops as you were saying
got traded by Magnus well E5 looks good
very nice classic taking the central
pandu well and Rook C1 H3 Queen E6 I
must say what Anisha is doing uh looks
very very sensible to my eyes King H2
Queen
D6 maybe menacing an E5 E4 in the near
future
Bishop H7 I always like these systems
where I had my Bishop tucked away
sometimes the fianchetto is nice and
sometimes this is also very nice Rook to
D1 I think black is ever so slightly
better I I like the center what can I
say I don't think it's objectively but
equal but it's preferable to play with
black maybe yeah it's easier especially
if white does something like E4 and you
get to play D4 and thank you for
voluntarily closing off your Bishop on
G2 let's go to one game we haven't
checked white let's do it it looks like
there also in some long theoretical line
mvl since he's kind of put his groonfeld
defense aside and he's picking up the
Queen's Gambit accepted has been having
a very easy life
he's not have uh nobody's really given
him a problem uh this move A4 seems to
be new bishop A4 Bishop takes Bishop
takes MBL saying okay you've got the two
Bishops
but uh what else is going on I'm I'm
gonna clear this diagonal so that I can
play Knight
to D5 and maybe Knight B4 because of A4
it doesn't feel like much here for white
no it looks pretty equal yeah
I just love I like black pieces all near
each other in the center I don't see any
issues for black Ransom from day one
where he had this magnificent win over
Magnus
disappointed with the last round yes
that hurt that loss to do that very
unnecessary just a blunder at the end
what has caught your attention Mark
let's jump into the Le bons game because
I think he might be getting some chances
there against a report so let's see here
so in this position if we go back it's a
critical moment here the move Bishop H6
is played levon's last move was the move
G6 and idea is actually to cover the F5
Square so the white cannot play the move
Knight F5 so here it was very important
to play the move C4 to be able to meet
the move C5 with the move Knight B5 and
in this case white would have a nice
Advantage now Knight can go to C7 or D6
and if you capture on B5 then you have a
nice control of the lights worse in this
position and E4 Pawn is very weak so
this was a very important move to play
for report and he's slightly better in
this position but he didn't play this
move and now he played the bishop Page
Six
and which I have to say looks very
attractive too uh and and surprisingly
Lebon didn't play the move C5 which I
find is very natural because now you're
removing the knight from D4 the Knight
cannot go to any active squares so you
either have to play the move Knight E2
or go on B3 uh Knight B3 and aren't I
rounding up the pawn on e4
then I have some ideas with G5 trying to
trap this bishop I can start with the
move Bishop H3 first
okay activating my Bishop
okay Rook F2 I guess yeah if you play
Rook F2 then actually G5 is very strong
now
my Bishop stranded huh Rook G8 is coming
yeah the desired Knight D2 walks into E3
oops so perhaps you can play after
Bishop H3 yeah you can play uh Rook fe1
okay better then I can play Rook G8
again the idea is to play the move G5
and Rook G6 okay so now it's time to
move the bishop now right
Knight E2 night night D2 walks into
Bishop G4 I'm assuming exactly yeah
G4 but looks like we have a move he
played the move Bishop E3 after Rook G8
yeah Rook G8 and again I think the same
idea wants to play G5 and now Bishop
went back so we can say that Bishop H6
white really didn't gain that much from
this move the only thing and now it
stopped black from castling right to the
uh King side here I would say that's a
lot yeah that achieved a kind of an aim
by the way I I do respect the move uh G6
uh G5 a lot
Bishop E3 is okay but
I would have been attracted to H4
instead of Bishop E3 like maintain my
Bishop perhaps and dark Square Bishop
trade in the offing bishop G5 maybe
H4 the problem is the immediate C5 as
removing the Knight and if you play the
move Knight G3 yeah and a very strong
move G5 anyhow really yes and now if you
take back Bishop G5 Bishop takes G5
yeah maybe not even taking immediately
you can even play the move King E7 first
because then you're going to take the
pawn on G5 and E5 and G3 pawns are both
going to be weak and black is actually
doing really well in this end game
ah wow stunning uh very
really surprising and he's played the
move C5 as you've been uh advocating
um
the VAR is this well timed
uh C5 it's it's it's okay in this
position but now white can play the move
Knight E2 and try to reroute the Knight
to F4 and D5 because you really want
this Knight on D5 because you have lot
more options to go to and if you play
the move G5 in this position try to
discourage that then I'm gonna try to
find another way to get my knight on D5
by playing the move C4 and then Knight
C3 and Knight D5 makes sense so timing
of C5 perhaps is not the the best moment
to play this move and 92 needs to be
played here for Richie
go back to our leaders game Wesley
against Dura because I'm not sure the
last move that I made H5
it was accurate wow wow that's an
understatement H5 is shocking
whoa
um not too many Defenders of the king
and
it's about commitment that pawn can go
back and now G5 is forever weak yes
um
well first question is if I jump and I
provoke the move G6
for
oh thank goodness for that because I was
well I'm a pond grabber
okay I did not know that yeah can I
I mean my Spidey Sense was tingling
I'm not it's not the grandest pond I've
ever won uh I have to say but at least
it's something uh different than our
normal petrovs
yeah I mean I think that's a healthy
Pawn
Health yeah okay uh but I was on G6
maybe you're not gonna you you you're
not gonna like me for uh playing G2 G4
that's that's a kind of a move where I I
burn some bridges myself like who's
attacking whom but I'm just thinking
that you only black pardon me only has a
single uh officer nearby these guys are
ready to pounce don't know is
opportunities knocking on Wesley's Door
bar absolutely H5 was a very risky move
I'm I'm actually shocked like you guys
right this is the oh I would have never
think about playing because opponent is
trying to get in Contra play there and
the move G5 is just the long term it's
just a really really weakening move here
and Wesley has few ways he can try to
obtain a pretty nice Advantage here I
will show you the the options here he
has he can actually just take on D5 here
because I mean the inclusion of this H4
h4h5 is going to be able to get a very
nice Edge so C takes D5 Knight takes D5
that was Black's intention for sure and
now you take Knight takes D5 yeah
it takes D5 and now we can play the move
Knight G5 now trading mate on H7 and if
you play the move G6 okay Rook E5 is a
very strong move
because now you're attacking on D5 and
you cannot play the move Knight F5
because of Rook takes F5 and then Queen
takes F5 will just simply be a mate very
difficult to deal with this move rookie
5 now because if you take a take D takes
and now you have to worry about the move
E6 right so you're gonna have to give up
a pawn here with the move like Knight E4
and I can just simply capture twice and
have a healthy extra Pawn or I can even
just bring the Rook into the game and
again you're going to be down upon and
uh very very difficult position here so
I'm I'm really surprised that he played
this move H5 but Wesley played the move
Knight G5 immediately and here black has
two options G6 or the move Knight D4
that you guys analyzed in both cases
white has an advantage okay night uh G5
uh go ahead and look at that Knight E4
just for a second because I I went Pond
hunting with Bishop take C7 does the
engine like upon hunting yes it's the
best Bishop takes C7 I love it I love
the confirmation eliminating the
defender Queen C7 is the only move but
again now C takes D5 and he needs to
come up with this one F4 maybe Queen F4
or Knight G5 both moves are playable
white is better in both cases let's take
a look at the move Queen F4 because now
you're attacking on F2 so I
I actually can play the move Knight F3
here this is a move just that
consolidates my position now F2 is
protected and also H4 so I'm just up a
pawn here so it's a hell nice Pawn
Advantage here for white but if you want
to play more forcing and just capture
only four
now you have Queen takes E4 Queen takes
E4 Rook takes E4 D takes C6
we're up upon but we have two pawns
hanging at the moment uh White can play
the move G3 protect H4 and after Rook
takes D4 Knight C4 and actually engine
likes this engine for white because the
weaknesses on A7 and C6 wants to play
the move rookie 2 King G2 double up the
Rooks even if we trade the Rooks I think
Knight versus Bishop y can press this
position for a long time so it's a
stable Advantage even here for white
wow remarkable stuff I I mean when I see
this move H7 H5 I'm a little bit
surprised that uh all we got all we get
is like a tiny a tiny advantage in the
ending you just think I'm gonna punish
my opponent you can't do you think uh
plant H5 is just Urban confidence
because duda's having such a great
tournament and when you are leading the
tournament you feel so confident that
you can make even Mosaic H5 work yeah
something uh definitely his confidence
is soaring but boy uh H5 uh is really
you know throwing a towel out there and
just turning our attention quickly to
the game of Carol uh and Daniel
um
it's always this question you know like
whenever the you have this tension
between the Bishops should I be taking
the bishop on B6 should you be capturing
the bishop on E3 and neither player
necessarily wants to resolve that
tension and they are both the youngest
players in the tournament right by far
by far yes Bishop takes uh uh
um E3 was provoked I want to say uh for
yourself uh Nasi what does your
intuition tell you about the move Bishop
takes B6 is this something that that
you're not interested in yes I'm not
interested in that I prefer to take F
Pawn and put it on E3 controlling both
D4 and F4 right you think you're a Pawn
on it but aren't you one of those
players that say hahaha I've doubled
your pawns and all of that the Dynamics
speak yes but you know I've played
neither with black a lot and I like
playing Bishop B6 and allowing white to
take on E6 and get double pawns myself
right that's why
I'm with you all the way uh there too
I'm not interested in Bishop takes B6
but we have this position uh
well uh classic Sicilian and reverse
colors I would say and we'll keep an eye
on that one uh magnus's game against
Danish because sure anisha's playing
pretty aggressively I would say
he's pushing here and he's pushing in
there he's in the opening yeah yeah we
left it at this point Rook D1 Bishop
dropped back Knight
F1 where exactly is that night going not
sure okay a little space B5 maybe if you
ever have to play D4 you don't want to
necessarily see a knight landing on the
C4 Square so B5 is useful doubling Rooks
wow B4 okay that's basically say my gosh
if I could land at night on C3 uh
I'm in charge B4 Rook C2
then even even worried about a rook C6
E4 plus hydroxy 6 and
uh
uh things are sure I want to say getting
very very Lively here my first
impression is that uh well I like the
open C file I take on C4 pardon me I
take on e4 I think I can take back with
the Knight because your F2 is
not defended I also have Knight seat
three options good good point uh Knight
takes E4 has a double
okay that is
that's sad are you going to play Knight
E1 instead because
I don't make that's not the way I play
chess I I don't like Knight E1
but now having said that can we just see
this again how bad is it necessarily
that I allow you a night on C3
you do get Knight on D4 but then a
little bit worried about your Rook on C6
it might get trapped uh well uh yeah
it's something yeah I I'm guessing I
should
play night here the weird part is I
can't even
challenge you
because of this of our jumping on this
one uh both players have trumps
Magnus has control of the open file but
this Pawn on e4 is is hitting the Knight
on F3 and there's this drums for both
sides Knight E1
uh I resisted playing the move Knight E1
uh what do you think of that move 91 is
fine I think that one line you guys were
analyzing D takes E4 Knight takes E4
very important move here actually is
Knight E3 Knight E3 immediately
attacking the pawn on D5 and ignoring
the fact that the pawn is hanging on F2
because actually if you take
on F2 right is just winning after Knight
takes D5
because there is a knight C7 threat and
just everything is just hanging here so
um so after the move Knight E3 black
needs to play the move Knight C3 which
is expected because that's why he put
the pawn on before to try to Anchor the
Knight on C3 but then you can play the
move Knight D4 and it's it still shows
about equality here and in fact after
the move Knight F6 it's a very
interesting exchange sacrifice you take
one takes C3 B takes C3 and you play
Queen takes C3 and you just have this
excellent blockade on D4 and E3 now you
have two on one majority control of the
C file so this is actually a full
compensation here for white in this
position so this was another way how
Magnus could have continued however he
choose the move Knight E1 here so let's
take a look uh what's going on there
after this move here Knight E1
evaluation is just equal at the moment
but Anish can continue play aggressively
now and play the move H5 in the Spirit
of the way he's been playing this game
Advance here and now get some activities
on the king side the king is a little
bit vulnerable here on H4 and this H4 is
unpleasant to deal with in this position
wow and uh the best movie is To Go King
G1 and again not an easy move to to play
there is a move H4 here G4 and then you
can try to reroute this Knight to E6 to
go to F4 and try to take an advantage
some of these weaknesses again it still
looks like a balance uh balanced
position but uh really sharp and it's
hard to play because you have to spend
some time and try to find a plant not an
easy position to play for both Players
let's jump to our tournament leaders
game between Wesley and Duda because
Wesley I gotta tell you when after he
saw the move G6 he's going for it G2 G4
uh a move I
I felt uh
could upset the apple cart thought that
after seeing petrol if we would get this
position yeah well this is the the this
may be a dream position because you it's
so hard to get an advantage against the
Petra move G2 G4
puts immediate pressure on the second
player I don't think you want to invite
HG Knight takes G4 where you can you you
can see Bishop E5 Knight S6 a lot of
weaknesses around Black's King no not to
mention that H5 might really really hurt
when you have the initiative in Rapid
chess oftentimes that comes with a
really nice bonus your opponent's down
on the clock what's the clock big time
difference here Duda is down to eight
minutes while Wesley has almost 19
minutes that's a big
huge Advantage with the attack and with
with the clock ticking due to feeling
the pressure and jump in VAR uh I don't
I mean I know the engine is probably
saying you can weather the attack but
it's not easy for a human player tell me
what uh what dude is suffering
absolutely not an easy position for do
that that's why he's spending a lot of
time he has to find the correct
continuation here otherwise he's going
to be in very very big big trouble so he
has to play The Logical way in my
opinion try to open up the center to
have some Contra play against the pawns
so he has to take on C4 here first D
takes C4 not intuitively obviously but
you open up your queen to try to put
some pressure on D4 and then you bring
the Knight on E6 because this will allow
you to exchange your kind of passive
Knight on C7 against a very strong
Knight on G5 so this is forcing the move
Knight takes E6 and then you take back
with the Rook
and now it's the White's position is
also a little bit loosier and the best
move is Knight G2 which I find very hard
to even play this let's let's take a
look if you take on H5 that's a problem
or the other H4 Pawn is hanging right
and suddenly it's uh black is doing
really really well here so it's it's
again you you have to find the you know
or maybe play the move D5 here in this
case now C takes D5 can be played right
and you can play Knight takes D5 and
again this will allow the move Queen
takes H4
Rook takes E6 Queen takes G4 Queen takes
G4 check you play the move King F1 it's
it's a really crazy line Queen takes E6
now you play the move Rook E1 not Knight
C7 Rook even one Queen F5 is absolutely
only move here you cannot go to G4
because of Knight F6 you cannot go D7
again Knight F6 check and if you go to
C8 again I think Knight F6 check picking
up the piece on D6 so you play the move
Queen F5 and now there is a queen C3
Now setting up a very strong Knight F6
check and now Bishop G7 yeah Bishop G7
and here you can start with Knight E7
for example King H7 and you play the
movie Queen G3 and you're gonna pick up
the piece on D6 so black has enough
compensation here after Queen C2 Queen
C4 so even at the end of this line I
think black is gonna be okay
wow but they are the top of our
leaderboarder Riot they are late in the
tournament and playing each other so if
this game is decisive yeah we'll have a
soul leader going into the last day of
Rapid absolutely uh D5 takes C4
something about that move I find
counterintuitive you are if you will say
surrendering surrendering the center
you're bringing the B3 Pawn to C4 but at
the same time just as you were saying
bro you're picking up important Tempe
against the weak well what could become
a weakened Center he did not take on C4
he played 96 immediately yeah I was
about to say it's not the first move
that came in and I wanted to ask for
what's the difference if we play Knight
E6 immediately it's a big big difference
Yasser because now Wesley can just
simply take only six right that's a
temple we have to take back with the
Rook yeah otherwise G6 will be dropping
and then C takes D5 just grab a pawn
well H4 is hanging are we grabbing a
pawn so easily c d e d c d uh CD CD and
then Knight takes D5 we are grabbing the
pawn oh nice and if you play the move
Queen H4 Rook takes E6 G6 is hanging
yeah you have to take uh Queen G4 yeah
then here you have two options you can
play King F1 or Bishop G3 if you play
Bishop G3 Queen takes E6 after Knight C7
uh White is winning the exchange here
and it's a big advantage
is it so clear uh Knight C7 Queen C8 you
take the Rook you take the Rook what's
the body count one two three four five
and you'll have one only one okay
and uh I can I can play let's say the
move D5 and somehow I thought I was
going hunting I I took a Pawn on H4 I
took a Pawn on G4 that was two but I
forgot that I was losing D5 yes that's
why the inclusion of D5 takes C4 so
crucial yeah and Wesley
uh seeing opportunity 96 and C takes D5
maybe you should jump to Richard's game
because I think he has an advantage
against Levon
um help me out here uh both players
coming into this game undefeated right
yes and uh plus one I think no I think
guys Richie last that game to Wesley
yesterday oh sorry all right sorry uh uh
let's pick up uh the pace here then when
we left it uh
who's Pawn whose epon was weak the E5
Pawn was that the weakness or is it the
E4 Pawn we left it we just saw uh and I
think you were advocating for Knight E2
bar Knight B3 was uh Richie's choice and
the players have reached
well a crazy position I think what it's
about to pick up that E4 Pawn for free
um at this point in the broadcast
nothing's for free uh
but maybe maybe
yeah after King D7 if you pick up on e4
I think that's what LeBron should do he
can simply take back on e4 and then he
has this excellent Square for the king
to go to on E6
and there's going to be a lot of
pressure on E5 and I think uh White is
still a little bit better here but it's
going to be very very hard to make
progress in this end game played like a
true Berliner Berlin end game player you
put your King on E6 you don't mind the
fact that you're missing a C7 Pawn it's
just that your king is very active in
keeping White's pieces out open updates
yes I don't know if you sacrificed or
missed it
does seem to have conversation we left
it after the move Knight E1 95 came with
a Tempo Against The Rook Rook returned
the favor hitting the queen queen D6 D4
hello in Knight C4
and Ani said why not
tags takes takes so we've got a pawn and
two pretty healthy passers here I can
imagine E3 92 Knight C2 one day Bishop
on H7 that used to be good is now
completely out of the game after E3 yeah
um
two connected passers
wow Exchange
bail is out on this one I'm still not
sure of my own judgment uh here uh VAR
what's going on the guest evaluation yes
if you say triple zeros I mean you
really are not going to be invited back
I mean I'm also surprised that all this
this balance here we see exchange
difference between one majority for
black and two connected possum but still
the engine is just showing all zeros
here but again let me show you how they
can uh progress here because it's not an
easy position to play I think the next
move for black is logical to play A5
sure he played Rook d8 already sorry oh
he played Rook date okay so if I was
another option so Rook d8 now Magnus
played the move Knight C2 which I think
Much Ado yeah he wants to keep his
options open he could play the move e392
but also he may consider also to put
this F1 Knight on E3 because we know
against the pawn only four Knight only
three's plays really really well in that
position the problem in that case would
be his Bishop on G2 is not going to be
the game so here A5 is a logical move
here right and he can start with that
move Knight F E3
and for black it's not so easy to make a
move here like you can no longer push
the spawns so you have to you have to
wait perhaps H5 you can play now you're
threatening to play H4 so now
C5 attacking the queen right Queen A6
give me the pawn on E2 and now you can
play the move uh you can start with the
move Bishop one
or even kg1 so at some point you're
hoping to get the Knight on C4 E3 maybe
at some point Knight Will land on D6
very complicated position engine is
showing uh you know equal but it's just
very very hard to play for both players
and on issues I think significantly
behind on the clock now that we know
he's behind on the clock how significant
just give me numbers
give me the facts Magnus has 14 and a
half minutes and Anish has six and a
half
more than twice as much time for Magnus
and yeah as far was showing us uh the
lines it looks like white has enough
conversation but they need to untangle
the pieces yes just couple moves if they
can put the pieces on the right squares
white will be better but can he manage
to do that and guess what H5 uh the the
the variation suggested by VAR uh on the
board I like the C5 Queenie too for me
it was kind of funny I like unraveling
with the move Bishop G2 to F1 defending
E2 what's my idea to play Knight to G2
and the other Knight to E3 and maybe on
a good day uh plant the Knight on F4
that will be my flag F4 and C4 tonight
yeah like something like that uh like a
good french defense player
um but
um big advantage on
um on on the clock VAR back to you how
is West doing and Wesley found the best
move actually he captured only six and
now he's gonna have a really big
advantage and I like his chances 12
minutes versus five and uh nice age now
so let's take a look what could happen
now so he he took he took some time
actually he didn't just take immediately
only six but after he captured he took
on D5 so he takes I think we're gonna
see that variation after Knight takes D5
uh Queen H4 so another alternative here
is the move Knight E4 wow but here it's
just simply an extra Pawn Rook takes E4
Queen takes D5 Rook takes E6 you have to
take back with the queen again and H
take a g takes H5
Queen G4 check Bishop G3 now Queen takes
H5 and now it's very important to push
this Pawn not allow the queen to come
back on D5 and blockade so after D5
Wesley will have a big Advantage here
rook d8 and actually you continue
pushing this Pawn again not even
allowing the move Bishop D6 and after
Rook D1 this is going to be I think very
very good winning chances for him so
after 95 now do that is still thinking
and he's trying to figure out what to do
queen H4 most likely is the move that he
will go for I think
do you had a question there I think it
was like 94. first I was gonna go and
point out how Pawn on G4 has just been
hanging there for a while yes no one's
doing anything about it right but even
the position where bar was showing that
white has pawned all the way to D6 it
still doesn't seem that easy because we
don't have the G pawn and our King's
exposed a little bit so it feels like
black has chances of you know checks and
yeah making it difficult for white to
win for for sure it's not uh it's
definitely easy game for two results so
that's already
an accomplishment for uh Wesley given
the time which is very important in the
rapid of course do this down to four
minutes now and Wesley still has more
than 11 minutes wow that's a significant
advantage
right and well I but I think you're
gonna have to take on H4 because I'm
looking
if white can play moves like I don't
know G5 Knight F6 get a uh well Rook
takes E6 of course is the most important
threat because Rook takes E6 F takes E6
G6 is hanging but if I get in G4 G5 I'm
just shutting down the king side and I'm
taking over the F6 Square so he took on
H4 I think it's rather mandatory and
whether you like it or not uh and he
played it yes that's his best chance but
I also just heard that Richie looks like
he has a significant advantage in his
game against Levon okay let's jump uh to
the second board and this is the I mean
if you thought this came out of a Berlin
well you you know your openings because
it it really did feel it and what you
were advocating there made a lot of
sense to me of our Bishop takes King E6
your king is nicely centralized keeping
the white pieces at Bay and okay but uh
different approach by Lavon King to C6
Knight to C3 gift me this beautiful
Square Outpost and that's what he's got
H4 tags takes
a significant Advantage here for white
the extra Pawn is very very meaningful
extra upon uh great pieces especially
the night on D5 and I love it
and the I mean Pawn structure is kind of
messy but I still prefer White Spot
structure oh big time and I'm just
saying you know like I don't know about
the move whether I should be trying to
stop B5 or not but I can imagine you
know he did put a bishop on F6 he put a
Pawn on G5 you just cement it just
played A4 to stop B5 and A6 because I
finally responded A6 right away it's
like the predator and the prey right you
know like I'm gonna stop you from
playing B5 no you're not so to keep the
pawn structure similar on the queen side
white can just play B3 and not touch the
B5 Pawn right right but I'm also
thinking can I take advantage of the F6
Square in another way by maybe bringing
my Rook to the file so that I can play
Rook F6 yes because I don't think I can
play Bishop G7 successfully I would love
uh that to happen I have ideas of Knight
E7 check as well
um I think it's formidable for Richie
but uh
I'm not a hundred percent sure of our no
Richie yeah definitely has a very big
Advantage I'm surprised Levon actually
played King C6 in that position and
allowed this Knight to remain on the
board uh his chances to hold would have
been significantly better in this
position actually Richie has many
different ways he can play uh he could
have even played the move Bishop F6
there
and we have a repetition uh I think the
players are ready to agree to a draw
they just want to confirm that they was
a repetition sorry we rather lost what
was going on they had a lot of
theoretical line and they Quinn scampi
it accepted yes yeah there was no
chances for either side so and by the
way Rook on G1 the F1 was played by
Richie and well Lavon said I'm going to
play B5 I don't care uh come hell or
high water I'm playing B5 in which he
said well it's not really that great for
you to play B5 uh Knight F4 with ideas
what if I play Bishop H6 because I'd be
very happy to go into opposite color
bishop and game not going to allow it
but G5 Bishop G7 okay nice now we don't
have Bishop F6 anymore unfortunately you
are true
um but I have to take with the F Pawn
and maybe you're not that happy suddenly
uh taking with the F Pawn
Rook F6 check is that kind of completely
ridiculous I don't know it might not be
completely ridiculous because after all
those are two connected past bonds and I
once was told a birdied once told me
that two pawns on the six rank are worth
a rook for sure I mean that was crazy
coupons no coupons at once so if black
can play King B7 King E6 real quick well
then it wouldn't be worth it
uh push I have to play Rook E6 and by
the way we might be uh we might be get
getting there VAR jump in with this
speculative exchange sacrifices they're
pieces yeah I'm analyzing that position
actually I have it on my board and uh
it's uh you have definitely compensation
but I think the fact that you know Black
is Black eating or the e-pawn I think is
going to be very hard to make progress
here gotcha but I think Richie misplayed
it a little bit I think he could have
had a bigger Advantage here I will show
you and so at this point
um allowing this idea where level is
really trying to play this move B5 so
here I think he could have just simply
played the move Bishop this is what I
really like okay because now let's say
you play the move B5 so it's very
important to play the move B3
so after capture black essentially has
no moves in this position you cannot
move the bishop talk to a bishop you
cannot move the light Square bishop and
then I can I can play Rook G3 Rook B3
you really have no moves so A5 it's the
one of the only moves and now you can
play the move group G3
and now you're trying to move the Rook
to B3 and then play the move Rook B5
this is a very very big advantage and
the most important thing is black
doesn't have any control play in this
position exactly and the current
position bar and the current position I
think livon is getting some chances now
they're actually following this line the
question is if we're going to see the
move Rook F6 uh White is still better
here but he needs to play the move
Bishop G3 here right that's I mean I
could you know pull in the horns there a
bit with the move Bishop G3 and wide as
far as I can tell is threatening Rook F7
and on a good day E6 yes so B takes c
will be played and in this position
um F7 Rook F7 I believe I have the move
Rook B7 now
wow you're not afraid of E6 huh
uh if E6 I can there is a move Bishop
takes B2 actually Bishop takes B2 like
it's suddenly better now wow
oh gosh I thought the e-pawn was uh and
you can you can sell it you can take
here and then play um King ticks and try
to bring the king into the game again
you you know if King C3 King see King C4
you'll have a big Advantage but now
after King C6 King C3 uh black has a
very important move rook d8 and
generating some counter play with the
move d4 check if you capture the pawn on
C4 so looks like black is holding this
position crazy uh diac again time
mismanagement
is an issue as he's down to 10 seconds
and how many seconds did he left when he
made that move he had the same problem
with anishin the last game and he
somehow won so right Anis got into some
kind of a blitz uh shootout so I think
and it didn't work yeah it can still
manage with the such low time he just
his position needs to be okay okay uh
Wesley so an exchange to the good when
we left it we we had seen these ideas of
Queen takes H4 dude that does not look
very happy and uh
Yeah but I
and we take a look and this is where
where I was asking I think we had this
exact position on our board some time
ago I was asking okay I'm going to
exchange up but
uh for a pawn and I've got this
blockading minor
um would you be absolutely confident
that you could bring this home with a
win again still done now
but I would definitely be playing for a
win and uh hoping that I can convert
this okay and uh Jump Right In for uh
the conversion what would you say the
conversion rate yeah evaluation is plus
two right now plus two you still it's
still technical it's not like there's no
like clear plan immediately to win what
you need to do is the first thing you
got to bring that Rook into the game
rookie one is a very natural move so
bring the Rook into the game and now
and now let's say queen C8 or queen d8
queen d8 makes a lot of sense the next
thing you want to do is put the pan on
D5 okay
and now black can play A6 just to make
sure the pawn is not hanging
then you play the move A4 again there is
nothing immediately you can do you just
want to improve the position next is to
play the move Bishop E5 and put the
bishop on this diagonal and perhaps try
to set up something like Bishop B2 Queen
C3 some battery on that diagonal
um if this Knight moves from D6 then D6
will be played immediately so this
Knight has to remain on the sixth
blackheaded d-pawn ah because I
absolutely wanted to play Knight F5 yeah
let's say five just this is very
discouraging Bishop takes DC Bishop
takes D6 Rook T1 losing and I'm crying
yes okay so that explains why I'm kind
of Frozen and we do have D5 uh Wesley
like myself I was a little unsure you
said the first thing why you said to the
first thing white needs to do is develop
his rook and I was unsure which spy C
file or e-file and then you said well
natural is rookie one Wesley said that I
can always bring my Rook into the game
he started with D5
Queen d8 on the board and rookie one
would be a straight transposition no
question about it but I was unsure
which was the more
um
advantageous file to hold the c or
e-file yeah you said the e-file and
is it a major difference for
um not a major difference even Rook D1
move is actually suggested as one of the
top moves in this position let's take a
look at the move Rook C1 which is for
yeah Rook C1 still still holds a nice
Advantage Queen F6 probably will be
played I guess the rookie won the
difference one difference I see is Queen
FC Queen F6 is never a move you have
Bishop E5 it was inside Rook D1 by the
way he split the difference between a
vars E1 and my C1 I mean yeah he he fell
on the fence
Rook D1 and you were about to say VAR
that Rook D1 is also a reasonable move
yes it is Queen F6 now can be played
activating the queen and putting
pressure on the bishop in that case now
uh White can play the move Bishop H2 or
Bishop G3 one of the squares
you have to use and if even H4 is played
it's okay just simply Retreat here one
thing you don't want to do is take on
this six I think if you take on the six
Bishop will take and it's gonna be
actually Improvement for black it'll be
extremely hard to remove this Bishop
from D6
a a principal question for you Laura
after Queen F6 should white aspire to
play the move Queen D4 into trade Queens
let's take a look I think black will
probably avoid the trade of the Queens
so let's Queen F5 probably I'm thinking
this way the move and now suddenly we
see some Contra play coming up with the
move Queen H3 so that's why the queen is
well placed on the tree because it's
covering the crucial H3 square and now
you need to respond and figure out the
way to protect the third drunk so for
example Queen E3 could be played uh and
now we see a evaluation is dropping a
little bit some Contra play now coming
up with the move between C2 so suddenly
Queen is active thank you magnus's Game
is hitting up so let's take a look yeah
talk about being exchanges up uh in this
particular case Magnus sacrificed an
exchange coming out of this middle game
when we left it we left it with these
two connected pass pawns we recognize
that there's issues
A3 broke up the queen side team
and Bishop F1 I like that move by Magnus
well Magnus is getting it going but yeah
definitely one fell uh that was the one
that fell he got upon back I think
that's a very important move by the way
E3 because this bishop could languish
after e35 white E3 and caught up with
the players
um I don't think Magnus is taking a big
risk here he's got King F2 Bishop G2 on
his agenda he holds this Pawn
maybe he's for Choice Bishop E4 Bishop
G2 on the board
so you're you're thinking Magnus is the
one yeah because well just because
you've already got two pawns right the
pawn on C6 is alive that's a real Pawn
the Knight on D4 is anchored I mean they
may look ugly but they're doing a great
job and Rook F Rook pardon me let's see
one defendant but I do believe that to
be the case like should be able to hold
this that also I believe should be the
case uh I'm gonna
well no I was about to say Knight F3
I trade the H Pawn for the C Pawn I mean
for sure I'm not taking any risks as
white but chances of winning are pretty
slim yeah with those doubled e-pawns and
uh vard jumped to you and what's
happening in Richie's game looks like
Rapport misplayed it a little bit and
now Levon has some chances here this is
the current position so he just played
the move B3 I think he could have have a
little bit bigger Advantage if he had
taken on C3 so let's take a look right
so we take C3 now actually he's up two
pounds and of course he played the movie
because he's hoping to win this Pawn at
some point they have two connected past
pawns but it's not going to be easy to
do it now uh Bishop f8 played perhaps
there was another idea with the move a
H5 here to try to create Contra play the
better option would have been to take
and try to press this position you are
up two pawns and there are some chances
here uh to win but Bishop f8 now played
and again the hope for black is somehow
to keep this C3 Pawn into the game
because if you lose the C3 Pawn you're
gonna lose this this end game okay well
let's go rookie rookie three make sense
directly attacking the pawn
and if you play King before that runs
into Bishop E1 really bad so you can
play the move King D4 we've got a Chad
Rook D3 check
King E4 ux and the point of the move
Bishop's fate we see now he's hoping to
play this movie should be seven and pick
up the G5 Pawn
and then he will have the one will have
two connected pass pawns so Rook C4
check
King F5
and
Rook F4 check
and again it's it's really messy and now
we're gonna see a pawn race
before white is up upon it's still
better here but again black have you
know discounts counter player thanks to
the two connected pass bones so
definitely Levon is getting some chances
now wow uh crazy things are really
heating up and these late stages of this
round uh Nasi yes the average time
travel yeah uh this game both players
have about three minutes jumping to the
Wesley so game as our two tournament
co-leaders are battling one another I I
just want to ask you again about the the
times definitely lower on time he's
playing with 30 seconds and Wesley has
two and a half minutes two and a half
minutes
against 30 seconds but
somehow how does whites break this
Fortress right
you
you did I just ask your question yeah
yeah you got it in Faster than I could
uh the move Queen C3 uh maybe sets up
for Rook E1 if you were going to ask me
how I could break the Fortress if I can
utilize The Rook on the open files Queen
C3 sets up uh the Potential Threat of
rookie one and rookie eight and again
what did you say about do this clock uh
he just made a move with three three
seconds on his clock three seconds count
them okay Queen E7 provoking
provoking D6
whoa I like D6 because on 96 I have
I love D6 and Duda immediately Wesley
winning will immediately turned his head
like oh geez
yeah and he's inviting Quincy seven
Queen B5 check
Duda looks ah yeah that was a horrible
move Queen E7 uh VAR yes Queen E7 is
definitely a very very bad move here he
had to play the move Queen H2 or perhaps
even leave the queen where it is and
play the move King H7 just move the king
away from the background uh Wesley is
still better here but it's not easy to
make progress here the Knight is very
strong on F5 and queen is doing a good
job locating this dip on it's it's very
important not to allow this deep on move
like in some of the previous violations
we were looking you always want to have
a piece black hitting because once this
starts this pawn moves it's going to be
just simply winning here and now I think
uh we've got Queen D7 the queen D7 Queen
C7 Queen B5 checked on the board yeah
and the best move is just to play uh he
played King G1 King G1 is invites Queen
E2
yeah this is not a good movie he should
have just played King E1 I take the Rook
with a check
so now
and don't I have a
I don't know I'll have two Queens on the
board that is two Queens on them that
sounds like it but what you can do is
give Queen G4 check first
I bet you I bet you he was planning D7
Queen takes forgetting about Queen G4
check so I wasn't sure I've just played
Quincy four pack
on Queen B5 or King E1 or King E1 King
E1 I thought in order to to push the
pawn up the board
um
back in the game it's a draw crazy he
was shaking his head in abject discussed
and now he's all smiles is it definitely
a draw there's nothing white can do
maybe what if I play Quincy one
give you a check King F1
King's gonna go for well I'll try maybe
Knight D4 okay you're suggesting Queen
C1 let me give you a check let me just
ask
some some questions Knight D4 so I am
threatening a perpetual
and I don't have Quincy okay
hmm
that might be threatening more than a
Perpetual I mean somehow this white king
could be I mean I can always take on D4
exactly even D7 but and and say give me
the Perpetual force it uh Queen E2 D7
Queen G4 check and that's the draw
absolutely it's going to be a draw now
after queen queen H4 Queen H4 check
a huge missed opportunity for Wesley and
because he's playing against his near
nearest rival you're absolutely right
but is that Queen G3 after Quincy for
check
now in the current position okay Queen
G4 Queen G3 and I take the rook in this
case oh oh don't do it yes exactly don't
stop
say King H7 and queen
oh my gosh
whoa Queen E4 check to avoid Queen G3
is it still Perpetual it looks like
because if I go King F1 you've got
Knight E3 oh my goodness
this has reminds me of the Wesley so
versus Richie report game
where it was really
tricky at the very end
King H2 it ended in Wesley's favor but
here
looks like it's going to be a drop
so he wants to go King F1 right
and the draw is expected in this one
between yes Richard and live on wow as
we go back to our tournament co-leaders
Wesley versus Duda
well Queen G2 made right yeah I was
trying to do maybe King E2 but I still
have million tracks
uh
you can simply even go Knight C4 King
f193.
now that makes a lot of sense
uh you'll get on your sneakers
Knight E3 check is that yeah
uh Perpetual because uh King G1 walks
into Queen takes D1 with a check
well I think Queen E3 is the girl quindy
one would be a little risky because I
can go King F2
and you escape perpetuals I might he
might okay but if you take on E3 I don't
think I can escape it
you have to take only three here
otherwise it loses only move yes
yes time again what's the clock time 14
seconds and he's done it
yeah I think so he has it now he knows
he's got to give the Perpetual check
prepared
King G2 the queenies for King G3
Queen has to go
and we might have all five draws again
no
yeah so
so we had uh an amazing day one where
sixty percent draws uh Gary comes on in
commentators curse says we haven't had a
single day of five draws
sorry I've got cobwebs uh
it's Queenie for check is that the
perpetual
or queen E7 24 or queen E7 both oh Queen
E7
oh my God yeah
and queen E7 is easier
Queen E6 no King H4 now
that is for darn sure
yeah
wow was it was very close
but exactly
a huge missed opportunity if he had just
played the move A4 there instead of
Queen C7 just to eliminate the queen
before I move yeah it was completely
winning for him
and he did have more time at the yeah he
played it too quickly there yeah he had
about two minutes still in that position
when he played this queen C7 move
so well this is a draw we can come back
to the handshake okay but let's check
with Magnus what's going on
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa uh just a
second
to play Anish is doing very well Rook d8
right now Rook d8 first of all I just
have Rook E5 like give me this guy or
give me this guy oh wait I can play
immediately
C8 oh gosh that takes a lot of the fun
out then I have to give the Perpetual
check is there a Perpetual oh yes there
is because I can go you can't go away so
we think C8 uh and I have check and if
you go to G4 I'll take the queen so you
have to go to E3 and he's done it he has
made a queen and this is the Perpetual
check I was referring to quite unusual
Perpetual very unusual
nice
I guess Anish will be happy with the
result since a good result for Anish
definitely lost the last round
good results relatively speaking you
know I mean you know it's been a bad day
for both of them yeah
let's jump to uh dioc uh versus Carol
this is uh this was the reverse Sicilian
and somehow
diac despite his many time trouble woes
is doing great once again King G5 is
playing for a one yeah I think he's uh
he's got every reason to want to
so somehow in the classical event in
Bucharest when he was in time trouble he
was losing but here in Rapid he's
winning from time and Wesley has made
the the prepared as saved
and will we see our fifth draw of around
no I think DX playing for a win but wait
what happened in the last couple moves
right he didn't go King G5 King G5 was
winning guys he missed the win King G5
was winning yes King G5 and then Rook G6
check
you play King takes H5 Rook G7 yeah and
then suddenly the move Rook B4 comes in
and it's not so clear what you're gonna
do with your Bishop you're actually
losing your Bishop oh nasty nasty C2 or
A2 invitation
domination
he missed a chance to win the game and
instead we have a current position where
draw rather feels inevitable
now
yes and if that's the case we will have
second five address five draws
what happened to our sixty percent the
size of games
players are making more mistakes we it's
not like no one had chances we
definitely had couple games go in
including this one right
in someone's face
especially King E5 inviting Rook takes
H6 Bishop takes D5
although I do see one Checkmate which I
think is worth
actually it's not even a Checkmate but
it is cute Rook takes H6 Bishop D5 if
you go King E4 Bishop C2 check as a
salute oops Rook H5 don't go King
yesterday there we go
have a quick draw here
and that's it
well uh
a strange start a strange finish our
round four all draws around six all
draws but we had quite a lot of action
in many of those draws including that
Richie that Richie mvl was and Western
clearly just now huge missed opportunity
for Wesley not only to have the soul
lead but also eliminate his uh the
person who's chasing him
let's jump to Warsaw and Christian and
Anastasia
and speaking about some of those
exciting uh draws guys of course one of
them was the one between Richie and Duda
in the first game of today's uh rounds
Richie first of all what a game that was
but I have to ask you one thing before
we start the analysis when you came into
the playing Hall you looked at the board
and you kind of started shaking your
head perhaps we will check it out right
now on the screen your
that moment right there yeah what was
that did you expect to play other player
or did you expect to play with a
different color what yeah sort of and
the other player comes yeah
but I mean I didn't um
as you could see the game it didn't
matter too much but
yeah it was a bit of a surprise what
were your thoughts going at that point
yeah you put your head in your hands
yeah I was like okay let me recall what
he plays I mean I played him recently
with white so okay it's not uh
um
total surprise yeah I mean in classical
so I I kind of remembered his repertoire
I'm just trying to
trying to to adjust
yeah my prep and you did play the Vienna
which was you know quite a surprise for
us uh we saw you playing it in class
cultures as well in tata steel so surely
you had something ready yeah another
successful day for the Vienna very
successful it could have been I mean
it was only when I was playing with me
but you know no I mean I guess this is
just or also like yeah I mean it's very
unclear actually I think I mean I'm not
so sure if Queen takes D5 was that good
actually
I think it's just very strong
now if he goes Queen yeah 21 doesn't
work simply because Bishop G3 and Bishop
G3 Bishop is distribution takes B7 is at
the end
I'm up with some bones
yeah but still
um kind of here decided so yeah and
queen display should have been played I
hallucinated something
stupid actually
as per usual what was the hallucination
yeah I was sure Bishop D6 what am I
playing but I mean instead of um
and uh I didn't see but I mean I can
just you know
it seems like the only move right now is
take on D5 yeah
no no Bishop takes this six actually it
works yeah take take and here the just
animal is winning But like after d takes
C4 I mean Bishop takes D6 DC4 yeah Queen
I mean I use Queen D2 and I just didn't
see it windy two apples punches
is covered so like Knight H3 and
rookie yeah yeah it's probably over the
king is stuck in the center yeah
um but even after Queen to D5 this game
was absolutely wild yeah I guess I could
have still played better Quincy check
instead of um
uh yeah here I'm going to C8 yeah I kind
of in Knight
h31 yeah this look like critical the
critical position and I I was I wasn't
really sure
um I mean I didn't see what he plays
obviously I felt like I'm kind of safe
but you know the problem was left foot
but I'm playing must be winning because
I'm able to bring in the Knight so I
figured with three attackers that should
do the trick but if you were close I
mean yeah I made this judgment call and
um let's lucky ourselves this was really
close
and uh we were analyzing it with Gary he
stayed for the whole world here in the
city and he was really enjoying this
game
um at this point I think he was
mentioning
Queen to C5 or perhaps I think it's
later on because neither three he takes
every time yeah and so like okay maybe
not not the three he takes previous
three this is only trick right so I have
to do it between C7 which I did actually
I just gained some time into the meeting
yeah so like here 93 right because he
cannot take them yes and then we can go
again yes
and I had like one minute so I just went
for it but yeah I could have taken the
opponent yeah
the idea I mean it's just absolutely
incredible you know the 95 King E7 holes
yeah I mean and we were looking at Queen
before yeah yeah sure and the King goes
to F no it's just um yeah it's very hard
to
I mean you know when you when you're
when you're little and you you you look
at these positions you're like okay it's
over again
pleasure right just by
not not too much no just by playing it
no no because you know I mean I have
given myself plenty of pleasure
yesterday as well by using two wisely
and I felt like I'm continuing giving
myself these pleasures of you know
throwing away half points here and there
so this was another example so you know
I didn't feel particularly happy with
this one or with the follow-up so you
know well actually that was another very
interesting game the game between uh
yourself and mvl and you had some
chances yeah we could say that
once again you started with the French
and you've played this in classical
chess against him as well uh you guys
have some sort of this ongoing battle
not really French so I just sometimes
play French and I guess 93 is kind of
principles yeah
and did you feel like you were
getting the advantage at any point in
this game yeah I felt like I was
completely winning I guess the end as
also often it happens
but now you know I mean I kind of feel
like you're torturing maybe this
interview because okay you're asking me
if I was completely winning in minus
five and I you know I mean okay
yeah yeah well it is rapid chess a lot
of these swings do happen
um yesterday was a difficult day
especially because of that last round
that you mentioned today you start the
ship a little bit slowed it down what
are the plans for the final day
I don't know I don't I would hope not to
be actually winning maybe that's that
film this week it has to make draws
without being winning
sounds like a
like a heavy person's plan yeah
otherwise it would be a very
painful day one way or the other for
someone yeah Richie despite the fact
that uh you know today there were no
decisive results in your game still just
incredible enjoyment for everybody
watching these games so thank you and
we'll see you tomorrow thanks
a very self-deprecating uh Richie
Rapport is somehow you can see how
dingler in and Richie got together I
mean two very very soft-spoken gentlemen
uh they're as well Richie diddly points
on the table Yeah I think that's kind of
clear yeah yeah that missed
opportunities you don't get so many
opportunities not against these guys
yeah so the galaxy of stars and uh a
quick look at our standings before you
sum up the day for us so far so we have
two liter Wesley so and young Crystal
with 9 th as somehow Duda slippery is a
eel Escape Wesley's grasp right and then
close the following livon aronian and
mvl right eight and seven points uh the
self-deprecating Richie report uh saying
why am I leaving so many points on the
table uh he's with 50 sharing with
radoslavoy tashek and Magnus Carlson
still with minus one our poll was wrong
completely wrong and we have dayak he
definitely improved today he has four
points and now kiril and Anish Kiri
share in last place with three points
exactly and
we have one more day of Rapid coming up
tomorrow six points uh up for grabs as
each game is worth two uh we'll see
around seven eight and nine and then
we'll split we'll we'll switch to Blitz
for day four and five
and uh VAR uh kind of sum up today uh
not the decisive number of games but
really a lot of action a lot of action a
lot of interesting games and definitely
missed opportunities by Wesley and
Richie here Wesley definitely he had
that game in the back and if he had one
he would have a two-point lead which
would have been huge going into the last
round of the rapid and on the other hand
we'll reached definitely he had a chance
against Duda and also against mvl he was
clearly winning that game in a French
defense and he just missed that last
move Queen C4 so it's it's frustrating
not to win the winning position but
again three more games remaining and
again six points Alpha grabs so still
it's a tight race guys so it's exciting
to see what's going to happen tomorrow
wonderful speaking of tomorrow uh the
lay the table for us what can we expect
in the pairings so for around seven
pairings we have embryl playing Wesley
so Marquee matchup right there Iranian
playing Roy tashek I'm both of these
boards players are just two points
behind each other right so they're
trying to even the score do the against
Geary against Robert and Duke against
Carlson who would have thought that the
act and Carlson would be looking at a
scores of four and five respectively
round eight
we don't know what the score is going to
be but we do see the players right in
round eight we have Robert against the
arc chefchenko against Carlson white
Tasha giri two Americans so Iranian
that's going to be huge and today
against San BL very nice and our ninth
and Final Round pairing for tomorrow
let's take a look we have mvl against
shevchenko aronian Duda that's it could
be for all the Marvels right giri
against Wesley diac boy tashek and
Carlson against Robert in the last round
will we see Bishop A3
anything we can see anything
help me out there
Wesley's Wesley versus Duda that was
such a crucial crucial game could you
tell me where Wesley missed the win
because it sure looked like dude ahead
of perpet after that Queen C7 Queen B5
absolutely could you bring it up I will
bring
actually let's have Wesley tell
us
I will jump to Warsaw he's with
Christian
thanks guys we are indeed with the
co-leader right now going into day three
Wesley Wesley a good day at the office
plus one but it could have been even
better especially because of this last
game between the leaders yourself and
Duda you had some chances to pass
through the game yeah for sure I think I
had very good chances
um
but
you know at the same time I go into
every game hoping to play my best but I
don't know whether I'll get any chances
to win or not so this one surprisingly I
did have but my first when you came in
the studio you asked me if you played a
good game and you did play a good game
so yeah that's my entire
in this tournament that should be
everyone's goal I guess if you're a
player but just try to play well and uh
try to play some good moves because even
if you play your best sometimes you
don't always win or you don't get
chances especially in Rapid and Blitz
when you know the variance is very high
yeah for sure so I think I I should have
won this game but at the same time I won
two games yesterday that maybe shouldn't
have ended in victories so it is what it
is but of course it's a Pity but I
blundered this King G1 we need to in the
end let's take a look at it but first he
played the better off which he always
plays his very solid opening so he
played this in Romania as well yeah so
you were expecting him to start with the
bedroom yeah for sure I mean he there
are many lines in the Petrov but he
always goes for this bishop F5 Bishop E7
I think younger stuff also plays the
Sicilian and some Knight C6 on the
second move but better off is a very
solid opening oh
not babe
I played the B3 first
um ah yeah this so this this game is
wrong
it might be because there were some
people I played perhaps touched the
wrong button just a second oh sorry my
bad
exit in just a second there we go back
to your game still getting used to the
leeches
but yes finally enough
uh you can write yeah finally if I if
you remember I played this a few months
ago against our friend dance Niemann so
I played 96 as black and he played this
new idea Bishop E5 and then I played
this exact same position against any
house iron in the finals of the global
Chess Championship
so I was white against antimon I was
black so I played it quite a few times
also playing some practice Blitz Games
but my game against nihal wasn't input
into the database for some reason yeah
so yeah finding good moves but yeah I
thought H4 was correct it means why they
slightly better definitely from a
practical perspective it did feel like
you were piling on pressure right now
yeah I was really surprised when he
played H5 because I thought Knight G5
and I guess G6 was a mistake you should
play 94 I guess G6 G4 because there's so
so many pieces
around black for example this
very typical break and your king is
actually safe even with the opening of
the G file yeah yeah thanks to the you
know if you have three minor pieces
that's pretty nice close to the enemy
King yeah like only a bishop
let's keep it going okay 96 was
something funnily enough I was
calculating Knight D5 but it doesn't
mean in fact
black if better
like I thought
white gets three points for the piece G
that is nothing yeah
it takes probably just a draw at that
point no I think you made the right
decision right now yeah click on the
fire transition into this uh sort of
middle game yeah but it's still very
forcing
like
didn't
calculating this but
anyway it's winning after H4 D1 D1 yeah
ah I missed Queen F4
oh yes yeah
some uh it's a nice computer maneuver
yeah
four yeah so apparently this is much
easier I mean V8
yeah apparently there's some Queen G4
trick which neither of us well yeah yeah
I guess white is better here but I
couldn't find a way exactly how to
was a mistake yes but actually only
losing a little bit of the advantage
you're you're still
however I allowed this Knight to move
I had to be very careful with my king
yeah I know nothing this page two and
this was the critical moment when he
played 27. sure the position is still
difficult for him but one two E7 pretty
much what a blender yes right away but I
I think it kind of rushed I should just
play Queen C4 yeah Queen C4 and then I
guess A4 Knight takes Queen deep there
seven yeah I was gonna play ee4
yeah I guess it's
totally winning but I just blundered
this Queenie too and then suddenly it's
a draw
yeah queen king G1 was just a terrible
blunder yes I was calculating we need
five and thought check I also got
including H4 windy yes DMV there's so
many options on the board sometimes you
miss one of them yeah yeah I I
before Queen E5 Knight H4 been before
Queen C4 just forget about this one
square yeah but actually it's funny like
it felt like almost your game against
Richie maybe he will try some uh
for more yeah with Queen to E4 yeah I
thought the
I I thought
yeah it's almost it almost wins for
white
so it's very
yeah funny enough with upon distribution
it's almost winning for white yeah yeah
but he found Knight D3 and this is
almost
almost yeah yeah he's fortunately got
Queen E7 oh but finally Queen E4 is also
under
although I don't know why
you got green F4
okay but this is some crazy like yeah
Queen F5 yeah so it almost went for
white yeah but uh yeah King G1 was just
uh
but okay maybe
um he shouldn't have
yeah he could have defended much better
well lastly how would you assess your uh
form after the first couple of days
because the result is very good so far
colliding the event but how do you feel
yourself could have fishy last year of
course yeah yeah he did really well I
think he ended up on 14 points well I
can I'm very pleased to play in Poland
very place that Poland is part of the
grandchester so I'm very grateful to be
for that and also to be part of the
grand Chancellor this year I think I
could have
played I could have scored Half Point
more in Romania
um and uh yeah here good start so far
but there's still three more days and uh
just uh
take it one day at a time I feel like my
main weakness is I need more opening
ideas like especially my wife
openings need a bit more deep
but overall I feel that I'm seeing well
that's good I'm seeing like I'm making
mistakes but I'm seeing most of the
ideas that's good that's good Wesley uh
very good uh good good game so far yes
one congratulations going into the final
day of Rapid
co-leading the event we'll see you
tomorrow go get some rest thank you so
much yeah thank you Christian thank you
Wesley the players are so self-critical
I mean uh he's having a tremendous
result and it's sort of like
I need more opening ideas and let's just
remind our viewers about the GCT uh
schedule of events that are upcoming yes
Magnus Carlson still joins us for soccer
right there will be another rapid and
Blitz event in Zagreb Croatia in July
and after that later in later this year
players will be coming to Saint Louis
for rapid and Blitz in November and
sinkhole Cup in November and December
remember our GCT tour players must play
in both classical events Bucharest and
singtel cup and two out of the three
rapid and Blitz events players with the
most grand chess tour points
become grandchild store Champions and
it's really that simple as Zagreb will
be our next stop after Warsaw but plenty
of action coming up tomorrow in the
Rapids and then we'll move to Blitz for
our final two days of Warsaw and your
thoughts about this round and the the
players a Richie so self-effacing uh you
know they don't really respect how
really good they are and nobody is
interested in in and who predicted and I
think I'm very interested
God believes it destroying us I'm
ashamed of you VAR yeah well my pick is
not doing that bad it's just only half a
point behind true that
uh but let's go to uh Warsaw and
Anastasia
you guys are you guys are doing well for
sure
you guys are doing well with the
predictions for sure I'm doing well with
the predictions
the ladies are doing well with the
predictions in indeed but uh yeah the
games were just simply amazing it does
seem like uh Magnus is still not finding
his shape but he still has one day of
Rapid to do so in the blitz section I'm
expecting a very Furious Magnus but we
still have one day until that Anastasia
what did you see today absolutely and
actually you know it's the games were so
interesting full of fight but at the
same time we had 12 draws out of 15
games can you imagine that only 3D size
of games it's like they heard Yasser at
the beginning of the show saying how
great it was you know to have so many
decisive results so I think there was
another great day like really like a
great uh day for chess fans everybody
was enjoying I saw them playing also
some tournaments just next uh to the
next door to the great event so
everybody is happy and that's the most
important right absolutely a lot of
exciting chess here in Poland a lot more
coming tomorrow so we will see you
tomorrow
thank you Anastasia thank you Christian
as we say our goodbyes we'd like to
thank you for sharing your day with us
tell your friends where you're hanging
out and join us tomorrow same time same
channel see you tomorrow wonderful
wonderful great calling the action with
you and Barb goodbye everybody
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited